Oh my dear dear reflin, what am I gonna do?
I'm all over the shop right now, I'm all bent backwards and out of shape and doing a backflip.
Sorry, I apologise. Good morning, darling. Vod watch, I hope you're well.
Right, gimme up gimme up gimme up.
Alright, what's the game called? It's called Elden Ring. Of course it's called Elden Ring.
God, Elden Ring is massive. Like, the size of the sails.
I'm connecting my controller. I forgot to disconnect yesterday so it's probably a battery.
I'm the sort of battery. I'm the sort of battery. I'm the sort of battery. I'm the sort of battery.
Shut up shut up. I'm the sort of battery.
Where is it? I'm the sort of battery.
Stop! Where is it? I'm the sort of battery.
Help! Please help. Help! Help! I can't tell! Oh, I can't tell!
Right, right, OK, OK, I got it. I got it, I got it. It was fucking high.
It's sorry. It was, I was hiding.
Good day of work. Good morning and good evening, and good afternoon.
Use Dyskords all over the end game. Absolutely fucking out. Why is it showing that.
Get the fire shit, is it cos I was...
Huh. My streamer mode's enabled. That shouldn't have come up.
mommy, the mommy verse, mommy's asking for help
um, hello reflans, did you manage to catch my catherina collab?
or was it too early? don't worry if you didn't catch it, it might have been too early
hold on, I'll unpin it, because, well I'm here now
and I need to pin, multi-player, oh that's all capitals
multi-bruh, catherina is so fucking nice, multi-player password
she literally just sent me that she's got an appointment for the doctor
I swear to god if my autism fucking diagnosed someone, holy shit
I'm unstoppable, I am unstoppable
wait, hold on, did I just mod someone by accident?
did I just mod you? no, it would have changed your symbol
I almost accidentally just modded a refling at random
multi-player or multi-player, more like melting the bosses because we don't do a
single thing, oh my goodness, lucky lord, mod on stream?
no, sorry I missed it yesterday, I was on my phone, no don't apologize
I completely forgot about it, I was at family breakfast, itadakimasu, is it yum-yum
in your tum-tum? the refling has risen, I'll take more
okay so if you weren't here for yesterday's agendination, please don't
we have completed the dlc, we currently are very naughty and have the
frenzied flame in us and we are going to remove the frenzied
flame because I didn't want to burn my fair maiden
half fee, hi, oh yeah
I got to keep my organs on the condition that
Katarina gets a correct diagnosis, that is the reason I was allowed to escape
unharmed because we were talking about organ harvesting, I'm like well I do
technically have three hearts if you need an extra one
no I missed the dlc, did you enjoy it? it was so good, we unfortunately came across
the glitch where the boss died
instantly so I had to get summoned into a refling's game which was actually very
very lucky, I should fast travel to frozen lake
or the freezing, you should travel to the frozen lake grace if you want to go to
the castle, okay freezing lake it is, sorry to make that
refling move that was just there, hi, yeah oh my god Katarina is a hoot in a
fucking holler, I felt so bad though she was like
oh you actually watched my content or like you actually looked into me and I'm
like yeah do your co-op partners not look into you?
like do they not, like I don't know, try and have fun like I asked I was like oh
what's your community name and she's like Cess and I was like oh mine's
reflings, and I was just like talking
away about yuster and I was like oh and you
know they're really happy we play Elton Ray like all that kind of thing
and yeah she's doing great things for the feature of her community, oh
Katarina is so precious she was like but she burped so loudly when we
I felt so emasculated sorry I felt like a pipsqueak of a man I'm sorry I've never
been more embarrassed I was like I can't even I can't even I don't have a
comeback for this I genuinely don't
um
you're literally the last name in my list from yesterday but there's only two
golden if there's only two golden it means
that there's only there is no way you're the last one
just a few have you heard she did with Emmys
I heard the start of Emmys one I couldn't finish it in time
that that's the only thing that annoys me about
um being a streamer I don't have time to catch everything so they were talking
about makeup um they were talking about makeup
with emmy and it was like if you could take away like one bit of makeup I'm
like so to peel the curtains behind
the back of it I don't think Katarina's gonna spank me
um 20 minutes before em the collab she sent me the
question so like I opened up a google doc and I was writing down my answers in
case I forgot whilst I was I forgot about that
em
there you go hi hi friends oh my god you're dripped out you're ready for the
drip the drip inspector already arrived oh you got fingers on you
okay oh I can follow you like a guiding star
okay take me take me I don't know where we're going so take me take me
oh he's got staff as well um uh yeah what happened in the end of the
emmy one I know they were talking I got to the point
where they were like talking about muscular guys
em and Katarina was like if I ever got into a fight
having a big muscley guy will like help me and I was like
what the fuck is she doing on the sides to me like fuck pissed at her
em and emmy was like I like I'm skinny and scrawny
um wait who is mourning in pain come come come
don't get fight don't get fight em she loves muscle men yeah
he out burped literally yeah literally Katarina was so nice I was like do you
play valorant she was like nah and I was like uh
I'm trying to put a team together for valorant but she said if I play pubg
hit her up and I'm like oh okay I might be putting a pubg team together
wait am I following this refland or the one with the brand the one with the
torch I assume I'm following this one you know what we're all just following
following the lead where's the other reef if I lost my child already no there he
is oh he's getting walloped he's half hell
the freedom of speech question brah we started tin foil hat and I was like please
I can't show my tin foil hatness I'll keep it in keep it in I was like
so katharina what do you think about freedom of speech and she went off on
one I'm like oh
eh where um uh I just keep walking
eh
Amy like skinny guys I think she said she doesn't like muscle men
I don't think it implies skinny though me like fat men I want big belly
I want fat and young someone sent me a marshmallow they were like oh
I want to fight with you over you like feeding me and I'll like exercise
ah is that supposed to happen
is that supposed to happen um yeah someone's like sending marshmallow like
I want to fight you you try and feed me but like I'll exercise to like annoy you
but like in a teasing way so I'm just like no sit down I want you to be a
fat ass basically
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
I where where down oh my god beef blend
reeflings you're scaring me oh my god I felt
my voice is really freaking broken right now
um I'm just rather unfortunate I don't know if you can tell how broken it is
um wow yeah yeah fuck that thing up did a
reflin just shagged something did you just kill something
why
hold on food chain thank you for the the membership hi we pinpo hello
food chain chugga chugga chugga chugga chugga me when I'm force feeding you
food tihi oh no this is lightning don't walk in
the middle of the lightning your voice sounds fine but don't
push it too much no um I don't think the stream is going to be as long we're
going to redirect into sheepsters um because once I remove the frenzied
flame then um basically we just roll the
base game and because we're all overpowered and I have the power of my
reeflings um we're done though and I can show
you my schedule as well I'm touching it I touched it
mmm where's my other reefling
oh he's coming okay there we go see mommy didn't lose a reefling today
I'm doing I'm doing much better today than I have in other days
she has to be off oh enemy time oh no stop not the reefling
I missed that was embarrassing I missed again okay this is getting rather
unfortunate it's getting unfortunate
oh okay I'm missing hold on hold on check stamina check stamina check stamina
check stamina check oh shit I'm getting frostbitten
standing on that oh my god that thing was
oh my no that's the reefling oh my god sorry reefling you're like right in the
way you're like right in the way oh
you got this thank you miss ma I'm totally not being carried hey miss ma
reeflings can you spam the miss ma emote
reeflings spam the miss ma emote the one where I put put you on my head
to show miss ma it's it's one of the emotes this is like the second last
emote like a miss ma I put your uh your fuji
tick as a as an emote it's so cute
I popped your I popped the reefling ones on my head and oh wait didn't I already
say I'm getting deja vu hold on a minute miss ma I'm getting deja vu I've
already said this before I'm sorry if I have t
em
thank you no I'm getting carried by the reeflings
we've already done the dlc um and we're never doing the base game I just
need to remove the frenzied flame from myself because I didn't want to
sacrifice my maiden so we're just doing that quest
now I'm just literally rambling whilst following
the reeflings around oh you knew that uh oh he's alive
are you like one hp in a dream uh feel like you can get up with katharina for
days oh my god katharina is so good at
combo she's so so sure she was like this story that story I'm like
I think my stories end within like by the time I became a teenager I'm like any
social story like stops
um but it's really nice like hearing someone say to life like that like I
I lived I lived a very different life but it was like rather similar as well
I was right I'm not going the wrong way are we going the right way
I couldn't hear until now hiya hi miss ma we got your emote uh as one of the
most uh
waiting for these emote artists uh I was using the same emote artists to keep
them all looking uniform but uh I'm struggling to get it
but thank you for the emote we're using as an emote emote
okay I'm up here is where's the other reefling have I lost
I'm a terrible mother this keeps happening how does this keep happening
I don't know wait you despawned hello hello should mage well I mean
technically you had a shot but how did you die right mage reefling you come in
again when I do a new one gav you'll come in don't worry
hello how did you die
miss ma your ace markable emu was very cute
emi and miss ma had a collab
or do you mean do you mean mimosa reefling
our mother dear mommy fill of what was the saying
and lead us into temptation amen thank you for coming to my ceremony whoa
oh my gosh whoa I'm getting freaking obliterated hold on
oh I'm getting obliterated dies because bad
yeah reefling two people with the lit don't worry I did it as well I got so
embarrassed I did it with the rain and um
I was thinking my barber and uh Yumi plus when it was still up and I was like as
soon as the words slipped out my lips I knew I knew
praise be to me praise be to reefling getting carried
uh what is this I go on this one
I'm going down here we're doing the fight
I don't know what this means
go down this reefling says go down this reefling says do the boss fight
no boss wait boss wait okay boss wait wait wait until this reefling's fully
healed he's almost done
shoni you just ended that reef I did it I'm sorry did I sound rude I didn't mean
to sound rude oh right oh right oh send the elevator
down how strange sure I'll send it down
but I will quickly get off it okay let's try that again
okay this elevator has been sent back okay ready I can't remember who's behind
here oh wasn't this guy he spawned
someone else on the team yeah yeah I remember I remember
I remember
ow was that reefling no no sorry it was the commander
thing that died whoa okay jump him make him regret being born
oh shit frostbite frostbite frostbite back up
back up him with sardar online
sardar online okay I missed
that was me I got a bit got a bit cheeky got a bit cheeky
a bit cheeky first thing in the morning actually I forgot I have a cup of tea
can I break his toys no I'm gonna get broken in
and that's a good pain
okay hold on let I need my frostbite to go down I'll do it from afar I'm
helping I'm helping I promise I promise I'm helping
oh you did it you did it oh I got an achievement too
did I go back the way
any chance you play life of pie unfortunately I can't stream snake so
it's not an accessible game for me I'm sorry oh his last blessing before he
went was to do this to me
uh what did I do now what do I do did I go here
go through the north store open the north
life of pie isn't all that wait is the life of pee
as in as long as I get the chance to fight
malinah
my booboo what do you mean my bubble doesn't last forever
how rude honestly right what's up here I have no idea what I'm doing I'm
literally being gay oh that looks rather sad
oh okay they have half the medallion Lord McKilla forgive me the sun has not
been swallowed our prayers were lacking your comrade remains soulless I will
never set my eyes upon it now your divine hell
the military
trist of urine oh that's actually rather creative I might even I might even
claim that was a tee he there life of pee is another soulless game
so the way they advertise it I swear they advertise that game like oh it's a
Pinocchio game you're if you lie this happens
and then you enter the game and it's a fucking souls game like what the fuck
have you seen the new warhammer game I know nothing about it but it's good oh
no I never saw it uh right we've got one half of the medallion
uh we need to get the other half of the medallion
which is somewhere space marine to the Pinocchio game
that's like dark souls basically right we've got the left so the right medallion
is located
oh where we fling gate me gate me darling
let take my hand take me anywhere you want
lunaria of the lake oh yeah piss right okay
lunaria of the lake lunaria of the lake lake lake lake
blue this one the lake shore southwest portion
but what's patch if you have anything near temple quarter
a bit of temple oh a wee bit of temple quarter right off we pop to temple
quarter I'm going to take a wee swig of my tea hold on I love when uh
vtuber's ask me to um do a bit more Scottish I'm like oh fuck you
yeah this is I was born for this quite literally let's go
I'm jahid wean
yeah unfortunately today is not an endurance I'm just warning you now
don't get too invested my voice is absolutely short and have a bit of
background work to do um shebe's got a shebe wants a youtube
roleplay script I'm not really quite sure what to give her
I asked her where she was interested in um and I just said I can just give you
plots that um I believe will be popular
because her newest asmr did not do well but it has all the elements of stuff
that has done well so it was rather surprising like rather
rather surprising um sorry you've not had a chance today
um I literally had all the elements of a
good audio are you gab you're not gab gab are you here
there you are gab you get shot and then if you want to become an enemy
refling able wait what
sorry are you an enemy
are you an enemy uh won't know until we start connecting
what haha what i'm suffered internet wait which is my
basically she be no not a live stream a roleplay
oh your enemy refling oh okay okay okay able me to
right okay that makes much more sense I was like hmm how did I get
three green ones in three golden ones in uh
she be um oh my god I I don't have live chat on
I swear if I missed any refling messages because I had freaking top chat on
I hate top chat I want live chat I want to see everything
um right let me finish my cup of tea but yeah she be uploaded a new asmr
roleplay video on youtube not a live stream um and I had all the elements
that um have been rather successful uh had I known
um and the video just like did absolutely shy saw
and I can't even make sense heads or tails of why not
so we're currently ab thumbnail testing it
um it's up to her if she wants to discuss why we are thumbnail ab testing it
and
how does top chat work top chat hates anything that might be bad
repetitive or offensive basically so I can't see when you claim you want to
ink to me and you want to ink all over me okay
bro that club with katharina was so good let's just like you have a bikini top
boom both of us in bikinis out of nowhere boom just like that
mm the algorithm does what it does
literally it was terrible I was very surprised and shocked at the same time
um I felt really bad because she be put so much effort into it now she has
fixed her microphone settings from that recording session
so the next one she uploads I'm gonna again I'm gonna try and pick a popular
roleplay I I'm gonna see if I can get her to
do a guide and we'll stick our review to remodel on the
asset from this she keeps shooting
I think it would be cute if it was like a guy who tingles you she has done a
live stream like that but I want to turn it into a roleplay because I think it's
quite isn't it
it should have stayed in the bikini longer I wasn't finished
honestly katharina's model is really good I like the detail
top chat also hides any responses that v-tubers do because they're repeated
messages I find impressive that these
reeflands can play with one hand how do you know I'm not oh wait
oh I was gonna say I'm doing the foot method but that doesn't count
right my little reason what and what are you ready
are you ready for an adventure yeah okay take me take me um
yes today's gonna be a wee bit smaller for streams
my foot the classic well you're like play one handed and I'm like
yeah I don't I dare say
um I ruined my what's your secret hidden talent
for katharina she was like don't tell me what it is
I want to find out live but then I kind of when she was like what's the most
outrageous thing you've done this year ow as if I just got me
um I kind of blew it I blew the surprise
but I can officially say I clapped my cheeks for another feature bro
ah Michael I can't take shit I can't get it that was glorious I'll look on her
face oh she's a hoot and a holler
honestly I'm definitely interested in putting a pubg team
together just so I can play with her more
um I'll see if she wants to do it after November
reefing reefing come uh or not or fuck up your choice
reefing heel kneel bark
you sounded embarrassed I get embarrassed to do it but like it is funny
like objectively to me it's hilarious I was like sorry I need to take my clothes
off for this and she's like what and what's your hidden
talent sorry let me take this off time let me take my weapons off okay we're
all together now oh I remember these balloons
did I miss the collab when did this happen this morning
uh I was on katharina's channel um and she's a cutie buttootie
fucking hell you ruled them whoa who brought the octopus
who brought the calamari yeah yeah yeah um I assume it's going to leave
us alone in a moment um a few hours ago
more surprise you have close to take off I've been wearing my
my overcool hoodie I really need to wash it though it's been getting rather
smelly rather smelly it was the best pretend no I actually did
out there I took my my armor off also I say armor
for the old algorithm reasons is why I refer to it as a pearl in armor
um when it's just basic cotton um
pheromone hoodie is it for sale I can be the judge if it's smelly or not
we vacuum sealed pheromone maxing shirt sales win
uh I was laughing at um oh no I wasn't supposed to hurt the wee crab the crab
didn't want to hurt me um oh whoa what's this poison
oh fuck it don't roll in it wherever you do
I know you're tempted to roll in it do not roll in it don't do what I did
it's projecting a poison aoe
oh that NPC okay I'm about to be poisoned can I get away with it
did I survive hold on I don't want to get poisoned I want to
oh no oh fuck I walked into it right I'm sorry
mommy's dumb get me out here I'm sorry sorry
I'm too low IQ for this area I literally walked into the poison after trying not
to get it it's a reef fling oh no it's a reef fling
throwing up no my poor baby
poison okay let's do that delicious do you have poison boulders do you need one
I can give you one no you got it you got it you got it
how well did I sleep unfortunately because of the collab I had to wake up a bit
earlier um I probably did six hours I did
oh I was kind of having to very quickly write notes together to
scrap um to scramble for the the audio editing team
basically it was a rather rubbish it's a bit of a pathetic attempt I'm afraid
wait did we just do a 360 I think there's a big old crab here
did we go the wrong way whoops
uh do you need a bulb this do you need one of these
reef fling I'll give you one how did it um okay
leave what what what what did I just do I don't I don't
I have no idea what I just did I don't I was trying to drop one
do you have your audio manager in place officially now
um
yes and no
um obviously I still do my own stuff because that's my preference
um I don't want anyone really doing my stuff because
I like my hands on approach um
I I fucked up sending away the audio so snowberries and
a snowberries are fucked up but after the snowberries batch is done
um then yes I am officially off of it which
um that batch is going to be done within like two days really
and then that's it we done so what am I to do here sorry am I supposed to do
something or pick something up oh there's a guy under the rock
oh what do I do here do we get progressed on right okay we'll progress on
I'm following you I'm following you sorry so yeah 48 hours it's like I don't
I don't touch anyone's patreons now though I just need to hand off the
information that's what is holding up but
obviously I streamed for 12 hours so as you can imagine trying to put a
document together to explain how like what what my my what I was
doing and putting it right in it down and what they need to do next yeah was
rather um hard to kind of string a sentence together
very very difficult wouldn't recommend um
and then oh jeez uh see yes with a long no and no in a roundabout yes yeah
unfortunately this literally hurts it's like
so I just need ac to get in place and then yes that's it but the only reason
ac isn't in place before you're like oh my god what's wrong what did ac do
no ac didn't do anything wrong I didn't send off her editing batch for September
so it's delayed but after hers is done
god those guys are nice and creepy um after those is done then
I oh there's a touch slate yeah then yeah I'm officially off of that part of
the team um and then I have one more responsibility
to give up and then officially I am just a streamer and a creative if they want
to script for ASMR hit me up if they want to analyze your content and be
told what's most likely to get popular hit me up wait what we're fighting
this no this is a human
uh oh is this this man that was hiding in the village
and then yeah I can focus on my replays and I can finally get my
work done is that break the pot
please no deal me
I haven't a clue no secrets lie with me not a one
oh please leave me be him he's hiding in the village you're not one of them
no
nice his mouth I was awesome don't say it
goodness me I'm albus and alvin auric
lion old mania secrets in his pocket focus on reefland streams every day for
well literally it means like I can do more ASMR clubs so it's more content for
you and we can start now doing my 1000
subscriber milestone and you guys actually request the ASMR
I don't just take a stab in the dark so again it's more content that you want
to actually see wait he just gives it up like that
then please give it to us oh okay you know what I've seen
oh I'm a wee bit slower
the medallion is the journey a quaint trend for dear
latin I just need this oh that's that gateway to get
into the magic place where my wife's mum is
his mouth is open because he's ready like uh I was like I was like don't say it
don't say it okay I'm gonna just follow the
following the reason are you still sore from
ring fit unfortunately yes I think they call it doms
late onset muscle soreness like goms or something like no wait that's a g
and late is l I don't know there's some terminology this like it's always worse
on the second day after exercise than it is on the first day after exercise
something like that I don't know I'm sure surely there's one gym
refling actually no get fat fuck you
stop going to the gym how do you
how you insult me so whoa dog oh no are you gonna disappear
oh please don't disappear get nervous when you disappear
I hate uh I hate you know
I'm feeling fat gym refling present amen
no this schizophrenia fuck where was like to go
what am I to do I'm already fat mommy good
did you go your belly for me
tell me what kind of food she ate next up grand lift of and use the secret
medallion grand lift of rod
grand lift of rods
fucking miss the home what have I not been there
this is grand lift that's the floor bell freeze
food the bell freeze in the mountaintops the white area
mountaintops grand lift oh the grand lift of rod
he had 10th is a man grinders rod is between
I'm losing my belly so you can make it get bigger later I get real
I'm doing a feeder audio I don't give a fuck I honestly don't give a fuck I don't
care oh stony you should be ashamed of yourself that's really dangerous
fuck you it turns me on I don't care
my foreplay is ordering take away with you that's right that's how you want to
start or two you're on a manual of dessert go to the left oh go to the left
start tee he gonna look
go up the line oh the grand old trick of list hoist medallion I present to you
a medallion
mommy wants to feed us chicken then our word is the refill star that's like the
best scenario like you're incapacitated because you can't move
and you have to lie on your back like that roadhog animation
and you're like uh too much and then all the blood was pumping
and I'm wrong medallion oh yeah piss how can I do the wrong medallion
no you need to switch action on the lift to say hoist secret medallion
okay okay okay right skipity boo skipity do that right hold on let me go back
down let me try that again hold on pause the tunes
pause the tunes right no let's try that again
sorry I got a little bit too much into it explaining
a few scenarios okay I was distracted I was distracted but for good reason
the first the boar now the feeding I think I'm in love
you're just waiting till dry right switch action hoist secret medallion
since you're into chicken what do you think about chicken nuggets from
mcdonald's yeah they're good do you use the
suit inside it I figured out the recipe for the dip
uh the dips in Australia aren't that good question mark
not to insult anyone yeah but you didn't taste that good
oh it's gone green for the reeflands oh yeah we have unlocked the next location
yeah
what kind of food messy no I'm not messy food doesn't really do anything it has
it just like take away like deep fried or whatever makes it better like
if it's home cooked food like a healthy perception
of it then it doesn't really excite me that much
but if it's like greasy take away food
how do you miss food spread food on your body make these things eat it off
oh I'm gonna commission that that'll be the first
time you've ever had a human version commissioned of you I've still yet to
your the human version of you is literally where the fuck am I
um the human version of you is literally just
the nicotine patch on your head and then like the white outline the classic
white outline and bent I what is this I don't
why is there death are you guys here
fuck you are here oh my god how did you know
oh how did you know how did you know right okay and you come and you come
and you come and you come save me save me there's death there's death afloat okay
there's death afloat unable to summon no don't say that
oh it's the game telling febbers wait why did it like you but didn't like the other
new ones no you're too far ahead you're in the enemies
you're in the enemies where the death is right this three films gonna help me
clear out and then I'll come get you then I moved my son I'm sorry I'm sorry I
don't know oh there's what the hey do you see
right throngler you've not had a shot to do
fetus chicken we've come through our word is and we lose weight someone we can
feed us again no you can't you're not no the whole point of you lying on your
back and not why is there death here if there's no death
something killed someone yeah what's going on
um where's enemy recently oh there's enemy recently
hello right and you come
coward fleeing deeper yeah I don't know where the end how is there so much
bloodshed here am I going crazy am I missing something
who are they fighting the the demons inside clearly
um yeah but the point of you lying on your back and not doing anything is
because that's like less work and even more calories in your system
yeah definitely to get commission
artworks wait I can't go in all right okay I can't
that oh my eyeballs sorry excuse me how's my balls are did that
raider riflin come in oh yeah there you are you loaded in
oh this is the invisible path play oh the invisible path play
um
moment you said you were into one I gotta know
does that one scene from men in black I've not seen men in black I'm sorry
I'm so sorry I don't know what to say
uh oh special a chip uh yes unfortunately I haven't seen
very many movies that are called and so forgive
forgive whoa the little guy around here is
right where we go this way
cousin blink
spank the octopus spank I'll take flowers though I will take a lot of food to
fan me up kid I like a challenge oh I touch lost grace
discovered oh yeah I'm discovering so hard plop plop plop oh no is this fight
what is this is that wind what's going on out there I can see a texture going
past I'm afraid I'm gonna have to ask for a cheeky
de-spawn I'm not really sure how to progress
it's an area challenge I missed this dream earlier how was your abduction
um my autism may have diagnosed someone who's been trying to
get a diagnosis for 10 years so yeah and thank you um half a 002 for the tip as
well I forgot to thank you by name am I gonna create am I not am I not to go
this way no no okay okay somewhere somewhere
new sorry somewhere new
uh date night idea but order pizza and fried chicken you feed me while we
watch the movies uh you need to get around to seeing
when the movies and food are done I'll lay down on so real
don't think I won't write that plot I'm uh oh my god stop you're scaring me
oh my god like this oh please okay and then a fake wall
okay and then what items this
silver scarab and then another fake wall
I'd get no not another fake wall
my phone yeah we so that she ended stream and she was like
stroney are you a doctor and I was like oh no I'm just really interested in
things I didn't want to be like I have super autism
and I really like looking at diagnoses online and I like looking at videos with
unique symptoms of things and whoa oh you're giving me a heart attack
is there item in here sorry just check him
you know we had just the discuss the rotism
whoa what oh it comes from the sky
what oh we got the critical hit
I'm slicing and dicing I'm a freelance doctor honestly she's like are you a
doctor I'm like I love Katerina but she's
obviously not heard me talk before I was like no I'm not smart
there's no okay pull ever pull the lever correct
correct lever somewhere a heavy door has opened I love the wee
sub-titles
wait why can't I swing geez it wouldn't let me swing because of that message
is that her uncle wait what the tentacle monsters with the long arms
because they're a bit touchy feeling oh oh no
oh no oh no okay okay okay we got this easy peasy
lemon squeezy what is it is it the cat no it's uh
slime got a fucking hate flame where did it go
oh it's me
oh my god we have to beat me up oh my god reeflands you're gonna have to do it
sorry I'm I'm gonna watch them beat me up spank me reeflands I've been a bad
streamer I've been a naughty streamer
how do you break my poise don't I have really high poise
oh yeah that's right I'm chugging my 10 drinks what you're gonna do about it I'm
using my art come on oh
come on
so mommy what a bad streamer she's been
oh fuck okay well that kind of just proves right now that
the yeah I would get fucking annihilated thank you for defeating me
you did great yep you did fantastic
hello what are you oh I dare through okay uh do we
than you to explore more hand away from your funny
oh my gosh you made me go I'm like I'm like 99% sure I knew what
piss you man I was like bro why are you getting me to say that but then I
started dancing to like to start doing like go back to the start then go up
the stairs and go left surely I will have compliment
refling oh god what have I done then go left okay
surely there's no enemies that are going to scare me and I have
a good sense of nerve this yes why not
I think it was pisski
oh god talisman
I'm scared to go down now where am I up the stairs and out
and then that's it sister we're dying to go next is this fucking hell we're in a
bloody mountain pass right I need to spawn you outside here
right hold on let me sit down you need to put your marker outside though
because if I spawn you inside the crypt it's not going to have you
could be aces piss coins oh that's actually really good
selling that merch right now right who's not had a shot today
alien sorcerer you've not had a shot
throngler you came erica
there was that ps4 game where like you had this like fluffy animal and you were
like running through like the baddies
throngler isn't it wait who's left throngler you were
just then so it's majory something um oh my god that's gonna annoy me
oh it was a ps4 game like playstation only
it was like aztec and it was like a boy in his big massive monstrous dog
oh my god last guardian is that the name of it
imagine us with a full belly laying down and using the color to pull you up
one doesn't say who's good
you can't be whispering the shit in my ear the fuck
right okay I'm ready to go if you're ready to go
look and do you know where you're taking me
the big dog with wings yeah yeah yeah that game I remember it was like
I always wanted to play it but it looked so scary because things start coming
after you but my name isn't sure it's
playstation only
yeah get b-lane to that to magic at it I have touched oh I like that
like a neon light the last guardian
ah I've always wanted to play it but I never got the chance because
I was an xbox kid I swear cat arena looks like she plays xbox games
so is but I was looking at her streams like when I collab with someone
I look at their recent streams and stuff
um just to get whoo whoa whoa whoa got
fucking legolas on a fucking wolf you just can't doon son you just can't doon
they are right I'm out of stamina unfortunately
you just can't doon saws but the wolf has to go
no that's it um oh my god the arrow literally on my shoulder like
oh oh that's kind of fucking hard this hurts more than the ring for the stream
you should play shadow of colossus is this dream state
I just finished the last of us today I've never played it I want to play it
for the first time
I told a fiverr on my debut to make myself look more
interesting as I'm like 99% sure I said on
debut that I played the game but I haven't
because I was like I need to pick things that people would be interesting
that was an adventure once until I got an arrow into my god
damn shoulder sonny you need a playstation 5 to play astral ball I
think you'd love that game
sorry for being late mommy you're not late oh don't be silly busy
it is a shorter stream today just warning you um
unfortunately you might not be able to hear it over the microphone um
my resting voice is down a few octaves right now
uh I severely uh damaged it yesterday and my um
and my enthusiasm to as much as I joke about like oh my god I wish I could um
thingy my bobber wait why can't I not let me register
it's not letting me claim it oh there we go um
I I just got really excited to like play for so long and talk for so long
I didn't realize until it ended stream I had um
on the left side of my throat if that makes sense at my voice box
uh I had like a it almost felt like there was like a marble in my throat and
I was like holy fuck um so uh yeah I was a bit worried about
like when I woke up I was talking to myself and
I was like holy fuck Katarina is she gonna hear this like on the voice spot
like I told her I was like I had a really fucking long stream
um whoa and I'm really fucking long stream
and I was worried that it was like really obvious like I tried to keep my
voice as like stable as possible oh wow I'm during the collab
but it's like fucking croaky almost like a tonsil so no we've had enough of
those for today power
power I can't see I'm just happy to be here
I'm just happy whoa I've got kung fu reef and everybody was kung fu
almost stamina you have to drink more yes I've had that tea I was sipping on
water during that collab that's the first time I've ever fucking
like being like oh make sure you drink too like I have to make sure I'm behaving
doesn't make sure you drink water Katarina don't turn into me
Scottish TTS there's no chance it's coming in I
would highly doubt that oh no no no I remember this is the fucking
shadow people no I have to do the shadow thing
again where there's like five assassins
no
I remember I remember I remember I remember
I'm beating I'm beating something up where are we humping
you can see the assassins if you quit the sentry torch
oh I'd rather just swing on their arses honestly
if they have a monster tts you got to do it in the shadow realm first
examine gazillionaire thank you for the 50
20 gifted memberships light the four figures of the ever goal
want to stand on this
hey thank you so much gazillionaire for the 20 gifted memberships I appreciate it
assassins gambit are you just like giving me it wait you give me
how many assassins gambit you giving me what do I do with it I can't put it on
my weapon thank you congrats to those who caught
it with your face come come coming
following I'm off are you putting me at the first one before you leave
tea where are you going god this is going to take a hot
second but congrats to be caught it with your face sorry I feel a bit over the
place right now I apologize
if you use assassin gambit you can light the things without being
attacked huh what
later without being attacked
well like right now or when that reflin leaves
he's just shown me the location so there's one at the start there's this
one I can't come
right okay hold on hold on I'm a little slower
when he leaves okay so we'll climb the tower the one on the bottom square
go once you've finished the tower go along the rooftop assassin's creed
style
to the blue ladder okay
and then we'll meet the third one
okay oh my god this is a lot of traversing for me
uh oh
come down
ah okay okay
yes I'm on pc sorry I had to send this journey
cheeks clapping earlier what happened I was asked what my like hidden talent is
and I was like I can clap without my hands so you don't have to give a show
okay this is the third one then where's the fourth one
over there did it go on the root no I'm gonna follow this reflin
like it snow ahead
go that way
roll onto this building
uh I don't know how loud it was clapping was it was loud for me I believe
I didn't want to I you know I didn't want to overstay it's fucking welcome
uh okay okay okay okay okay so the one on the ground
then the blue ladder is pretty much uh is the
the task okay and this is the fourth and the last one
surely I'm not gonna get frustrated mess this up
surely copy them surely surely and I can also roll onto this apparently
okay right and we're back at the start right so
where's that fourth one that was on the ground it was back there somewhere
I'm sure I'll find the ground one rather relatively easy honestly
do I need to kill the assassins or can I just beat them up
oh it begins okay examine light the thingies examine enter
ever go right oh fuck I've already forgotten the path
um what was it uh oh piss I've literally
forgotten already no this was wrong a refling didn't take me this
way you know oh my god they're after me I'm coming
oh there's that second one right there on the floor right hold on
just knee it back I'm stressed okay I can't do this game on my own
okay hello light flame okay just follow refling refling took me this
way there's actually a refling with me right now you just can't
physically see him and that's okay that's okay
fuck off bitch fuck off poor bitch bitch fuck off
stop it oh oh my god sorry it was the shadow of someone else it was the
shadow of someone else that's came up here it's fine
it's fine it's just the shadow of someone else that's come up here before
I'm fine there's a refling with me okay light the flame
gorgeous then we're gonna hydrate
and then I need to remember where that other one is and I can't for the life
of me fucking remember
ah I literally can't remember where that first one was
oh my god right okay this is the third one so
fuck it we ball where the fuck is this other one
light please oh my god it's here it's here I heard it's swinging
it's swinging ah okay it begins it begins where the
fuck is the last one it must be up it has to be up there's no way it's not up
it has to be physically up there's no way
how could I have forgotten the refling literally walked me through the bloody
path up it has to be up up is the only option
right if I get stabbed again the good news is I don't die
oh you're pissed right I've just done a fucking circle around
my heart is beaten please be nice please be kind to me
I'm solo IQ hold on up ground ground what oh you fucking pisser
oh my god I'm out stamina lovely yep yeah fuck off you little
stay on the outside and look for a ladder look for a ladder
not about any hydrate this this will please be this one
oh no it's not that one I know for a fact it's not fucking that one
how could I have forgotten refling you took me so far
oh no it's west in the corner
hmm like over here this way
all right I'm going up I'm going up I'm going up I'm going up I'm going up
like you're swinging how the fuck no I'm about to pull up a map I'm actually
about to pull up a map this is getting no this is actually getting
switchy go where the fuck is it
no pause no oh my god this game doesn't have pause
this game doesn't have pause because why would it why would it need pause
seriously why would it need pause isn't it so fun
when a game doesn't fucking have put I'm getting shagged on a fucking ladder
yeah right right we get it drop down please drop down please just drop down
oh my god what is even getting me I don't even have any long range weaponry
is it that way is it that way it looks like that way I'm going back sorry I'm
going back
oh I assume because there's an archer there it has to be in that
this way right that's how it works right that's how it works how the fuck
did I get up without this archer fucking shagging me
oh my god I need to do like a stupid roundabout way right in front of the
assassins I'm about to get grabbed I'm about to get around
I'm about to get grabbed I need to go this way
northwest north way oh and I'm out of stamina so time to get
grabbed I love being groped oh here he is
here he is oh oh fucking fine why can I not find
anything to get me up I need a viagra I can't get out
I can't get out
maybe I'm just special maybe I was born with it
well I was but that's beside the point okay something something's not clicking
who or what is shooting me when I go up this ladder it looks I'm
I'm confuzzled I feel like it's up here it is up there right how'd I get up
mm-hmm I can't kill the assassins kind of right it looks
like this is what it is right so let me hear
fuck you I know you're here oh go in stairs on the back
okay stairs on the back hold on stairs on the back of this building
please get up the stairs
yep feel free to take your time no it's fine I'm in no rush at all
please this is it this is it this is it good morning
good morning oh my god don't ever do that again
a seal was broken in town yeah that's the only thing getting broken you're
fucking hymen what the fuck was that it was awful
oh I did a lot better than the first time I ever did that I just couldn't remember
okay uh now what I have no idea up the stairs
up up the stairs upstairs okay upstairs I'm going up the stairs
I'm going up the stairs all the dududu
ooh that touch it
read message examine why yeah someone knows once you teleport once you
teleport okay
did I grab the armor under the stairs my armor
oh
oh can I even can I even get you here oh there's a
is he gonna go for me
gently easy touch the grace site easy right I hope I've got some
long range reflins because I definitely do not have long range
right decks you've not had a shot today
and then who's not had a shot so rush isn't had a shot
and then who's not had a shot I've been a mini will be niche lump when you've
not had a shot at all
oh did someone who failed
did you follow up man I feel like okay decks came in but sir rush couldn't come
in over zero did you move your thing
hmm uh Jess you've not had a shot don't worry sir rush I won't count that
against your name to get out okay
oh shit no that's how you use a boom not the way I'm using that stuff
okay be careful no one follow me oh okay careful no one follow my game
crashed oh no sorry okay I'm ready to progress if you guys are
I'll just let yous carry me through this terrible section because I don't do
long range as much as I want to I really should actually learn how to play
magic in this game you'd think after like what my third
playthrough I'd finally figure out how magic works
I still have not figured out how magic works we go on that tree
I'm following you
yay hi chat I'm on my happy plane we're good we're a little sleepy heads though
oh there's ants
I like how the notes were played off tune when they'd like do an attack
maybe next playthrough you and sin do magic oh I'll definitely do magic because
I've still yet to do it oh oh
riflin
you fell off riflin I don't think I can go back and summon you I think I'll have to
summon you at the next point okay the enemy riflin jumping down there
whoa let it ring thunder
I'm sorry you died okay I'm following
oh that hurt a wee bit that was a that was a lot on the knees
how did that ants attack in this game
I can manually do that part madness this is madness this is
sport uh hey hey I've never even seen that maybe actually
warming stone this new grim did mod is not oh whoa whoa whoa there's spores
there's spores oh oh oh oh oh oh there's spores
will summon please think of the spores
oh my god I'm so sorry to the riflin that's behind me I'm just getting you
covered in spores right now
okay this definitely is the hell
little tree oh sorry sorry oh I just stopped that
riflin sorry with my big button away excuse me can the contraption does not
move okay I guess we're at my my oh almost just
did that you you saw nothing oh I can spawn a rifling here
I can see my house from here uh is there any rifling
oh I can't open up the menu I can't even tell you what this is
I'm so sorry how did you manage to do that I'm so sorry
is there anyone who's not a chance oh I need to go heal
sorry something my mommy's feet imagine smell oh you
this journey you have never seen 300 you'd love it with a
guess we can watch it together is there anyone who's not
you've not had a chance to be no uh Jess I'll take your name out because you
died well that doesn't count uh literally
spawning in to fall off a tree does not count as a as a shot to play with me
okay I'm just saying that now I'm saying that now
oh we're posing we're posing hey riflin reinforcement
uh you don't look lonely okay let's go
the smell 300 has a lot of slow motion I read
somewhere that if they had all the slow motion played in
the movie would be 30 minutes longer oh did they just have like really good
scenes like that whoa
get off the map I don't know well
you're braver than me I was backing up
okay down the stairs gently well it's not full
I'm not too very cautious safe because we're on earth are the uh
whoa what are you doing oh oh come on I hit first
here we go
I remember when uh the hobbit came out and they were showing scenes of the
I said that's not Lauren Dell what the frickin the the place that begins with L
um and everyone was like there's no
like uh how you call it balcony like the wood that goes beside the balcony
riflin did you trigger that plan where are you
are we in trouble
I'm to come this way
jump scare
right let's get rid of this
mmm railing that's the word yeah yeah yeah like they would on say sorry I've
just completely lost the inability to uh speak today like say words and things
and stuff and it's all gone no recollection
300 was written and illustrated by Frank Miller who did since that he
the Zack Schneider directed it uh the only movie he made that was good in my
opinion and your humble opinion oh I'm picking up the I am
are you whipping us you think come here oh the point got it I got it I touched it
to see the point
maybe
you're whipping oh what oh didn't we not have to like kill these weird snails
is that what you're doing right now I think so yeah you gotta like twerk on
the snails or something
that was a little how do you they already know the spawn locations are just that
MLG how did you make that jump that seems so long I fucking okay it's fine I
don't know how where I am oh okay it's fine I can I'm coming up I'm coming up
I'm coming up that looks like a really big distance
like a really big distance oh fuck I'm up that piece of tree deserved it okay
can you rest today um yes so we're gonna finish the
I'm gonna get rid of the Fire Enzied Flame and then we're doing the base
like an actual base game which we're really overpowered for especially when
I have you um and then um I'm taking the rest of
the day oh and I will show you my schedule oh I
should probably show it now shouldn't I I think so how did you did you jump
across that
oh wow yeah I don't know how you did what you did
um hold on let me show my schedule uh I'm getting my nails done today
uh yes that's related to the schedule that's why I'm bringing it up
um
I have a very big surprise you know how I was telling you oh I'm so excited
um about the stream snipe this week oh can't wait to do it
you want to know why oh hold on where is it
no that's the game where's this
where is it
no stop where you do it what I can't show it I know
uh oh okay I hold on I'm having a stroke I'm not the good guy
where the fuck is it
uh right hold on let me just do a new fucking image source I guess
what the fuck
how strange I don't know why that wasn't working
uh I'm not uh normally sorry I know you're waiting on me in game I'm sorry
I'm sorry boom there we go the reason I'm so excited about
stream snipe this week is because you get to stream snipe me and
she be we're playing life for dead two together so both
harem and reeflings can join in with us in game
we're genuinely doing a stream snipe game together I'm so excited
and I'm gonna do my handcam Lego set building I'm gonna literally I'm
getting my nails done today and I don't know what color I should get I
don't know if I should get alternate in colors of nails
are you gonna be doing versus mode no you're gonna come play it with us
you're gonna I've never played life for dead two so she's gonna
help me through it um now there's no membership ASMR however
there's two ASMR streams this week and
I'm gonna play chain together solo I know the irony the the whole point of it is
to not do it solo but there there's a very easy screenshot if you want to
screenshot it and then have a little analysis of it
how long will left for dead two last I might not be able to catch a person
um it is completely depend not to put any pressure on sheevy
but um I have quite a lot of stamina for stream sniping
um are you okay are you consoling each other what's going on
really funny okay um whoa
definitely um I don't want to pressure sheevy to stream too long but uh
the way it's going to be done is through my stream sniping account
um because I don't think she has one and I would like her to be super
safe um so here I'm and reeflings can add me through
my stream snip account um if I wish to continue on forth
um I will where's reefling right root reeflings going this way
wow behave um are we doing this fight first
or they're saying don't do the lift Johnny please don't lose another nail
no no no my hand hand nails always grow back
uh hand nails I'm not getting my feet done I just getting my
coming reefling though wait
uh oh it's just me and you reefling um
why are we going I didn't even take we're not to go there
um if sheepsters can't go for a long time can we keep yeah yeah
I'll keep playing with you you know me I'll try and play so
I don't I'm so confused I don't know what you're trying to get me to do
tihi you know that's another one literally losing my children
whole willy-nilly but yes um sorry as I'm trying to freaking formulate a
sentence um I will stream snipe further
um like so then it would be like three
ah okay I guess this is a fight if I've ever seen one
oh there he is right it's a guy on a horse
oh my gosh it's guy on a horse whoa okay I'm sorry
what is this whoa sorry I'm trying to enolize the magic
and maybe I'm just overthinking it no no uh he he's strong he got a few whacks on
me I'll be honest
oh jeez
it's a lady on a horse no one's there
oh special attack
I'm helping I'm helping
oh there we go easy easy lemon squeezy all got an achievement
Loretta a knight of the halloween tree oh weird more like
knight of the living dead because you're dead yeah
oh take that thank you reef land did I go up that lift now safe until next
grace in your face I'm needing a grace like
this is a berserker where I hate fighting her
reefing strong together I left an item oh god where
at your feet
I don't see anything golden this this looks a bit golden
did you give me an ovary get my ovary out here
you're done you're done get my ovary out here
uh I guess I keep going this direction right I'm gonna sit down so I can reset
my things can I level no no don't level up
sure just put everything in the house because
I don't really see why not
is this a lift
no good sort ahead nothing ahead okay uh did I use the lift back there
left for dead too yeah it's the first time I've ever played it so I'll be curious
how it goes oh it's a statue I like the candles
in front of the statue bit of environmental storytelling
no I do I do staircases you're at you're going the right way
what staircase I never saw a staircase I saw a tree
I was a staring at it oh my eyes did not even look at that at all
like I kid you not my eyes did not see this
they couldn't have ignored it harder um
yeah still sad my pops killed my life for two oh you're dead
uh okay we're slayed in
uh why is there blood
why is there blood I hate when they have blood what does it mean
you can summon once you go down the elevator and leave the building
okay I hope there's blood because someone was a silly Billy
whoa whoa oh thank god I can summon here okay
right bounty hunter you've not had a shot today
bounty hunter
yeah it's faith but it's faithish uh
dexterity bitch
or are you guys just really unlucky and have the same name okay and then enemy
refling rief guardian okay rief guardian liviosa
I love it's really nice that katharina got to experience um
harry pourr for the first time oh my bro you want to summon the fucking yaps you
you're off watching more the rings you know how to call
ghosts but there's
people find crave ways to die it's like running when the elevator isn't there
I think I've done that myself a few times okay we have a fight on the bridge
hi wait how do I say hello
oh quivering coconut yeah that's what I want my coconuts
a name to be quivering I'm quivering with anticipation
that was fucker
yeah you're not doing that to me twice you did it to me yesterday not today
not today whoa
did you see that she like because of the delay she like coated her
lady with a needle hold on I need to clean I need to clean the
greasest greasest site site of greas
hello again we meet hello I can only
surmise our purposes are aligned in that case
allow me to explain myself I am off millennia's blood
yeah
an offshoot we better extra just a little further
okay I must return to millennia what her arm
oh the dignity the sense of self
that allowed her to resist the call of the scarlet rot
the pride she abandoned to meet redone she's got the red hair
there is something I must of the will the dignity
so now that we've spoken to her what happens next
I'll like you nodding your head like oh yes I understand the dialogue
all right I'm gonna change point forwards to that nod
I want to do the head nodding I'm gonna go let him know
oh no I'm not locked in
warm welcome made the best one uh right okay uh
the gods do be filling around a little cheeky bicky
and you plead in oh reefling oh reefling send your ink onto me for the
sins of the and where they must be baptized in blood and come
okay enough enough I'm being rather outrageous today
um okay where we go further
never met sorcerer cell and you really did avoid sorcery like this like
I'm I just I'm very small-brained when it comes to me I don't understand it
okay did we just continue on to the
no don't call for reinforcements you stinky
no stop calling for oh he's about to spit fire
I think he did oh now you're dead
okay I following the reefling
the reefling
also me my voice is broken I can't speak
me as soon as I get the opportunity to sing a little song
or a jingle that has your name on it
I really didn't want to be more careful
whoa
jump here
uh oh you're split who am I going with down down
use of me like a banana and split making me nervous
down from behind
people whoa what are you throwing
oh reefling careful I have a very long sword
I'm gonna hit you with the end of it by accident I hurt you
okay I'm gonna grab this light and you put
hey hey oh I'm healing I'm healing
in the ink we are one in the ink we are made of all
all different colors of vets of ink or something like that
sometimes it's better to sink in the ink than to ink in the sink
wait a minute how is there blossom I'm backing off
I don't know how there's so much blossom
I got a stone inking let's go
oh I remember this boss baby whoa
no leave memories alone mine my problem my responsibility get out of here
what's that people stand on top of the tree
I guess we just go whoa hey what
oh my god I forgot about that I forgot about that I forgot
I forgot I forgot it was like
I forgot oh oh hold on let me hydrate
hold on let me hydrate let me get rid of the weak guys first I'm helping I'm
helping out jeez the fucking bow and arrows okay hold on
hold on I'm going for the bow and arrow guy
because he's fucking me up do I skip
do I skip oh my god ow ow ow ow do I
oh I can't even get out I need to hydrate like you know
I can't even get out so I'm away I'm away you're afraid now
I'm getting shagged and freaking spawn no fuck you
shit he's a better knight than me no
oops
hmm oh at least my souls are right here
and it's reset so the evil one that was hard
okay let's uh tingling on that again shall we
do you want to kill that boat I mean he is right there
we're in the lyric of him carpet bomb
you don't have a chance to do carpet to bomb
carpet bomb
big fish smart sign of chance today
and then who's enemy weflin
so I see an ashi oh the misery everybody wants to be a bumblebee
what color should I get my nails actually no I know what I'm going to get
my nails on us because it's evil it's so evil you
you won't understand it you won't understand why I need to get my nails
on that one
I know what I'm going to do I know what I'm going to ask for the nice lady to do
your golf it has to be black no
ah my game no elton ring stop it you you do do it
elton ring keeps breaking for me
my game broker this right let me remove those names they don't count
everyone liked it oh I see everyone liked it as if it wasn't my game that
broke there but it's funny why are you so cute
well because I can't stop leaking
yeah my game okay hydration check
um
I think I'm probably actually gonna go back to sleep
if uh if this stream like if we end up like bum rush in this because I think
we're about to um I think we'll bum rush
this uh yeah I know the progress didn't save you
the game broke on me I had the audacity to ask the game to
so if it's not black well you're making french style
I'm gonna get very unique nails oh I thought it broke again oh my god
um I'm gonna get very unique nails oh I just sat down
okay and there I uh stop okay right no more putting the signs right next to
the bonfire I'm gonna cry okay um right over zero you've not had a chance
today and I'm sure that the color of my
nails are do not correspond to anything at all
not a single thing I'm sure of it in fact hi hi
sorry I couldn't no no don't be sorry hope you have a good rest of your stream
I will thank you stash power you don't have to
you don't have to apologize because you can't catch everything
bro I can't even catch up with my own streams I'm gonna watch back the
catarina stream um
which um excited about uh because when I do like a collab I never
remember what's going on in it okay we're ready
hi are we just moving through this place
or is there anything in particular I need to do do you guys know does anyone
here know what we're doing because I don't I've still not removed the frenzied
flame so we're not doing the boss battle yet
now I have Emmys toenails in my mind me I can't visualize what evil nails would
be in a no evil nails why'd I have no not evil
nails that I need to spell out
are you gonna make me spell out for in frustration
I'm on my high recently yet okay I'm gonna get my nails done like a gen two
design there I fucking said uh the nails have been finalized on one of the
designs I was gonna get her nails on me as a nod to her
there there's your secret spell okay can't I see
I'm fucking called out honestly pick up item oh this is the poison area
okay poison poison poison
right don't roll in it that take the bulbous now
or is that just good is it not gonna like have a resistance
right we're off oh my gosh oh my god is it faster than oh it's faster than that
holy shit you're so smart I'm like a frog I'm going the wrong way but I'm like a
frog okay I fucked up this is awful
wait oh my gosh it's like eating me up so quickly
bro it's building so I don't remember doing this like at all oh my god come
fuck off now it's not the time for this
I don't have the HP for this I'm not smart enough to do the backwards roll
thing okay hold on oh my god I'm coming very very slowly
it was kind of obvious okay thank you it's an empty space yes I would like to
heal here
careful oh I missed I missed so uh no don't make me wash off I want to
be nice and simple I'm gonna pick up all the
whoa
no don't clap at him that reefland just embarrassed himself he probably feels
bad don't clap at that that's stinky don't worry I'll take your name off the
list that doesn't count I'm sorry you fell off the map
don't clap at him he's already embarrassed he's so mean
okay let me take your name off the list to make sure I don't add that does not
count as a as a gaming session with me if you fall off the tree
maybe he likes being embarrassed oh yeah you should feel so embarrassed right
now everyone watched you fall off man you fell off
wait how did I touch it I can't warm up then we're just healing up here
boo game crashed boo
good to see you hello is there anyone here uh smart oh I had you but then the
game crashed I swear if you crash my game I'm
taking it as an attack again over zero you don't count
so you'll be coming in later I'm sorry I'm late I had a friend no don't
apologize if you like for stream you goofy govers um if you're
wanting different content I actually did a collab on katharina's channel
um that you can check out summon does a cooperator
recently did also that had daily
I need pee again I can't believe it with my increased intake of water to try and
help uh my throat wait what were we going
they're saying this way
I need to tinkle more it's terrible it's okay gaming
I think you should do a quest line before the boss just in case it turns off
summoning uh am I am I still frenzied
flamed though I think I'm still frenzied framed
I'm sorry mom I missed one second we've seen what comes forgive me
you need to do dog's ma the Japanese thing we take off all your clothes and
bow down do dog's ma right now I don't I can't remember how it's
felt dog's ama dog's ma dog's ma
together together together give me together right now
what did you wake up are we supposed to kill this
or I don't recall uh I don't recall hurting this
as I recall it hurting me though
does it have a health bar I can't even see it oh wow you got critical on it
uh do you guys have like far away attacks so whoa whoa
I'm gonna get pushed off of them it's so big how are we supposed to fight this
um
no my reeflings die you fall off the map as well
oh my god I'm getting walloped by this thing
what are you saying here hey to heal I'm not sure I can leave that per reefling
on his own I'm trying to help okay
I'm trying to help
oh he's massive I can't even see his health oh there's his health bar
whoa I think I managed to roll perfectly
oh my god we did it I don't know how we did it right who died who died you don't
count on the list yes smore that doesn't count you
died like in sling hey get the item
I'll get it very quickly oh is that supposed to be like the bait item that
you go in and then that thing just appears out of the way and you're like oh
my god
we're now we're now we're
you don't have to put these then wait glowstone
what for
go up pumping
oh
are you poisoned why is your health going down
I'm look they need to leave you need to quit to the menu reload the area I need
to quit you need to fight us
I need to reload the area thank you reefling
I can't quit the game when you're in it oh I suppose that makes sense we wouldn't
do that okay what if something happens here
let me uh let me be transparent
uh I still got quit yes quit and then come back
sitting on the grace it's great
there's screams
I need to do the fight with the NPC or it's all girl
okay do the fight with the NPC or it's all girl
this one right be summoned to assist
be summoned to challenge assist or challenge
make sure you be summoned to assist assist
see something okay you got there
assistant okay whoo what are we doing okay uh sure
does she die if she dies does that mean like completely balls the up for real
oh my god
whoa yeah you're definitely a freaking sister to that the scarlet
raw oh come on
pov I'm not with my reeflings for five seconds I'm
fucking dead already
pov I don't have reeflings holding my hands
for five seconds
oh no does this just keep going on and on and on until I don't mess up
hmm my circle of pod streamer can't be this useless
oh I'm not sure about that one chief don't put it past me am I supposed to
like that vague vague lovely okay let's just pick on the same one at the same
time I'll use her like a reefling oh I'm out of stamina
okay let's use her as bait surely fuck she's in the field that couldn't have
gone any worse
nope can I no can I get the first hit please instead of you
ah one more one more come on don't run out stamina now you lazy
fucking frog oh you frog honestly
oh thank you right what's going on in here
yeah let's just use my ultimate oh no whoa I didn't realize the fucking
AI was going for me you just you just relax no yes maybe this was it
real
oh my god did it second time okay I just have to think the NPCs are
really true okay now what rotten winged sword and
sycnea oh I've not seen that one before
raises dexterity rotten winged sycnea what was it greatly raises attack
power was discussed at the tech okay that makes sense
no reload the game it goes
from software
Where are you?
Are you here?
I'm here.
No, she dies?
No, you did so well.
Hello.
Thank you for lending your hand.
What's wrong?
I could not have defeated that quartet.
I feel as if I've been in your debt from beginning to end.
Thank you.
With your help, I was able to live as my own person.
If only in passing.
But this is where things end.
I was supposed to even tell you.
But I took out the needle myself.
Tell whoever put you up to this
that if I am to flower into something
other than myself,
I would rather rot into nothingness as I am.
Oh, what?
Please.
Let me pass alone.
The scarlet dropped right now.
Worse than ever.
Soon.
I won't be more than a mound of flesh.
Cursed lady.
Untouchable.
I wouldn't want such a thing to bring you home.
Please.
The scarlet soon.
Cursed lady.
I wouldn't want.
Okay, okay.
Oh.
You didn't have to die.
Namco.
Oh, she didn't have to die.
Sorry, I'm a bit sleepy today.
Oh.
She's going to be like a puddle of flesh now.
Oh, fuck.
She passed away.
Oh.
Old and young.
Visions of love.
Love will love.
Old and more.
Teleport to drainage channel.
Does that have that unlock?
No, I do.
This is the sad souls.
Everyone is dying.
She didn't have to die.
Grim dark souls war.
Honestly.
Wait, did I go to the right place?
Yeah, I did.
Is that something you said?
Am I supposed to do something?
Say no more.
You don't have to tell me twice.
Right.
Who's not had a shock today?
I swear you're the other one.
Carpet bomb.
Did you lag out?
You did.
You're the other one that lagged out, so you don't count.
Over zero, you fell off, so yeah.
You don't count either.
And then who's my enemy?
Oh, my enemy.
Smart.
He's a bumblebee.
I have a pen that has four different colours.
If you're wondering if you ever hear a click in the background,
I write the enemy Wiefling's name in red,
so I know not to count you as like an actual person I called in,
because it's not the same when you can't like, hit stuff.
It's a bit different, yeah?
Yeah, we can hear it.
Sorry, it's a four coloured pen.
It has green, blue, red and black on it.
What ending are you going for?
I want to cure myself of the frenzied flame to show my maiden
that I did it for her,
and that I didn't do it because I'm lost to madness.
I did it for her.
So, I'm going to be Elden Lord,
because I've never done the Elden Lord ending.
I've done Rani's ending.
And did we Makarani's ending?
And now I want to become the Elden Lord,
because I've not done that one,
where I just sit on the chair.
I assume it's the sit on the chair one.
Does she know?
What?
I'm getting rid of the frenzied flame.
What do you mean does she know?
I got rid of it, so she's alive.
Don't say does she know.
No, she doesn't know.
I think she's talking because you pissed her.
No, she's alive.
Fuck you.
No, I did her a favour.
I'm to go all the-
Oh, right, okay, one at a time, one at a time.
She'll forgive me.
Whoa!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh my god, carpet bomb died?
No, there's no way I'm counting that.
Sorry, I'm taking your name off again.
There's no way I'm counting that.
Oh, I got Talisman.
Sorry, let me take your name off the list.
That does not count as an attempt.
Nice try though.
That's a very good talent.
I believe it.
Let's get out of here.
A booty fly.
What would you want?
You are my gating star, everyone.
Oh, I missed.
You didn't see that.
That was so embarrassing.
Don't these guys cause lead damage?
Or am I going crazy?
Oh, whoa.
Careful what you wish for!
Careful what you wish for.
I'm not that I wish for it.
Okay, I'm ready.
Sorry about that.
Oh, chap.
Shall we?
What to do now?
I'm already letting them feel.
How much health have you got?
I'm really healing you slowly.
I'm healing you slowly, so slowly.
I have my reef length, my reef length.
To call my own.
Oh, no.
Okay, let's try that again.
Who's not going to try?
Don't die.
I have to write your name one more time.
Don't fucking die.
Do you understand me?
That's an order.
That's the third time I've wrote your name.
Don't die.
Don't disconnect.
Don't crash my game.
What's the message?
We're going for the Ranny End?
No, I've never not done the Ranny End.
So I'm just going to make myself Elden Lord for one.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
Yeah, yeah, you better be sorry.
Spank, spank, spank.
Don't crash my game.
Oh, it's a fight!
Oh, what's behind door number one?
Operation exists.
this. Okay, ready? Let's see. I can't remember what this fate is. I remember this fate! Oh
no. Oh no, this can't be. Okay. Oh no, this can't be. Have fun. It's up to the reasons
to have fun. Mmm. I remember. I just helped your sister. She's got all the faith on you.
No I do. Because that Scarlet wrote fucking it out. It's tearing her up. Well you'd be
legs to the arms, to the prosthetics. You chicken nugget boss. What a level am I? 200?
In like 17 or something? Does that mean I'm good at games? No. Oh! She really said
My flesh was dull gold and my blood rotted. Corpse after corpse left in my wake. She's still
conscious. Elden Lord? I don't know Elden Lord. Okay. Uh huh. Uh huh. And I will be your shield.
Monka? And I have never known defeat. Yeah, until today. Make take me a few attempts. Oh my God! Relax, relax. This is embarrassing. Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, back off, back off, back off, my cock, off my cock, off my cock, off my cock. Off it, off it, off it, enough, enough.
Fuck. She have high poise. She's better not. Get off it. Oh, I lost that girl. Well, hold on to me. Oh my gosh. Okay, so she can be staggered. That's the fantastic news. Like truly fantastic. But I need my stamina to come back.
Okay, let me back off. Let me back off. Oh, you got frost damage. Nice. Ah, how did I get caught up in the wake of that? None to do with me. Take this. Take this. Take this.
Pop, pop, pop, pop, pop. Get wall banged. Get wall banged. Hold on. I need hydrate. I need hydrate. Take Agro. Hold on. Right, I'm coming in. I'm coming in. That was me. That was me. It was all me, baby. It was all me. Right, okay. And I'm for the butterfly part. I remember the butterfly part. Okay.
Really damn, she really dead, didn't she? Phase two. Fight.
What am I looking at exactly? She's so sweet. Looks like a tree, a bit of bark. Love one.
She really said, it's right behind you, isn't it?
Is the music the leader?
Oh, I love how beautiful this design was.
Oh, our bibs out. Wait, is that a-
Sorry, I had to zoom in there.
Is that? No. It's a scarlet roll, wink, wink.
Did I not register this the first time I played through this game?
Wood. I don't- Oh my God, I forgot all the attack patterns.
What is she doing? Yeah, yeah, yeah. Get ranny'd. Get ranny'd. Get ranny'd.
Oh, get ranny'd so hard. Oh, pick up someone else.
Someone else. Oh, I missed. Oh my God. Is that why I thought the design was so beautiful? She ain't got nothing on?
Honestly real, though.
What does this do?
Whoa. I assume if you're in the blossom, you get scarlet root tissue.
And that's why it has such a-
Oh, we're swinging. We're swinging in unison. We're sinking up. Oh, not quite.
Hold on, let's keep it safe. Let's keep it right.
Oh, we're doing it. Oh.
At least she complimented us. Most of it.
The true Lord.
Literally, most of the-
Most of the Lord, like when we kill the Lords on the way out,
they all are like, oh, you're not fit, tarnished, you're not this, you're not that.
My brother. I'm sorry. I finally met my man.
They're always like all insulting, like you can't do this, you can't do that, you can't do this, you can't do that.
This is the first boss that's like, oh well. Yeah, you're gonna be Elden Lord.
Yeah, you didn't win.
Is it okay? Excuse me.
I think only Melania and Joff Godfrey compliments you.
Now you have to reload the area. See no more of them.
Quit the game.
I'm level 225, oh my god.
Just a cheeky bit a little bit, yeah.
So, I'm probably gonna go for a little cheeky nap.
After screen.
And then I'm gonna get my nails did, I'm gonna be a girl.
And then I'll take pictures.
Oh my god, I should take pictures.
Sheevee did that, hold on a minute. Sheevee kind of kicked.
She got her nails done and then she took a picture of it wrapped around a figurine.
And I was like, hmm, smart.
But none of my figurines have arrived yet, so I can't really do that.
I think, I think bad bagging takes a whole second.
Right, I'm reloaded the area.
Oh, you're new, hello.
Hi.
Return on a Lloyd gold needle?
I've returned the needle.
Return.
Okay, Makilia's needle and a smithing stone.
Insert the needle into it.
Plop, plop, plop, plop, getting started.
Plop, plop, plop, plop, plop.
Okay, now I did.
Now it's off to Farham, Azure.
Gosh, I can't remember any of these location names.
What is this one?
This one?
Farham, Farham, Azure Delay, see no more.
Godwin is chill with you sitting on the Elden Throne
because the Tarnished are descendants of Godwin's soldiers,
his dad's army.
Aw, that's nice.
I'm glad that there's some people that accept the Tarnished.
So are we basically just a rank one soldier,
a blade of a rifling, so what name?
Are we just basically a rank one soldier,
and that's why everyone's been really mean to us.
And that's why, and they're like,
oh, they hate you.
They're like, oh, I'm sorry.
You played at the stars.
Are there any other riflings that haven't had a chance to do?
Never go.
Shieldmaster, you've not had a chance.
Shieldmaster.
That honestly just sounds like another title for a turtle.
And what animal is this?
It's a shieldmaster, of course.
He wants to be the naughty with one.
We're not royally put it that way.
You are cannon fodder.
Oh, that makes sense.
People are so resistant.
Cannon fodder cannot become Elden Lord.
And I was like, ah, okay, thank you.
Don't have to be so rude about that.
Like, I'm just trying my best.
Seriously.
Just a little undead little guy.
You'll have to kill one more optional boss for the cure,
and then you can finish the game.
Okay, tell me what boss to kill.
I'll do it.
I want to cure myself of the frenzied flame.
I won't make a good game.
We're curing myself of the frenzied flame,
and then you need to kill the king of dragons.
Parathrax!
Oh, my heart just fell out of me throat.
Oh, my God.
I'm okay, though.
I thought it was ogre.
I'm not even kidding.
Is that dragon gonna lock onto me?
That made my heart jump, too.
What do I get for reading and playing video game
at the same technology?
You are basically a random NPC,
and everyone's mad that an NPC's going...
They're like, damn, this wasn't in the code.
Fuck.
I've touched it.
Let's go.
Parathrax and Beal 1v1 each of them.
Oh, this place just creeps me out so much.
I'm so glad I'm super overleveled for this area.
Teehee.
And now nothing can scare me.
Wink wink.
There are three boss fights here.
I know there's a jewel in this area.
I don't know the other ones.
I missed. That was embarrassing.
Whoa!
I'll just pray it's friendly.
Yeah, damn.
Jew, Micoleth, and Parathrax.
I'm gonna just...
Oh!
Something just walloped me from there.
Who was that?
Rude.
Okay, where do we go?
Where do we go?
I don't know.
A ball bearing.
Whoa, really?
Hmm.
Huh.
That's a lot.
Look at them jumping behind a rock.
Go.
Naughty.
Naughty!
They're like blending in my idols.
You can just hear these balls.
Ding-a-ling-a-ling.
Ow.
That poor riflin is getting...
Oh, my God, mean riflin or bumpingy.
Oh, okay. That was really dangerous.
But we got...
Whoa!
I'm gonna just run ahead, okay?
Rifling, no!
Can you make it out of a rifling?
Are you fine? Are you safe?
Jeez.
Jump, and then jump.
And then clean the site.
What are you bumping?
Hmm.
I have to keep my cock with the rock.
Whoa!
That was a bit dramatic.
Okay, I missed. Two of us can do that.
Ow.
As if we could do that move.
Don't you align me.
Such a cheat sheet of horror.
Whoa!
Okay.
Are you serious?
Stop aiming for the riflin.
Aim for the enemy that's, like, point blank, maybe?
Jeez.
Pillage corpse.
I'll pillage the fucker in that corpse.
Uh, we do...
What now?
Is this not where the twin's here?
We're about to do the twin...
Riflings, I hope you know how to win this fight
because I don't remember a thing about it, okay?
I will go forth.
Don't! No, don't!
Do that.
That's scary.
Am I not...
Oh! I was like, it's not working.
Alright, what are their attacks again?
Oh no, he does, like, a circle spiral thing!
The big one does the circle spiral
that you can't, like, cheese.
You just, like, forever get to.
Oh, you put them to sleep?
Was that supposed to?
Oh, they're molly.
Are you putting them to sleep?
This is what we're supposed to do?
I hope, anyway.
Now, walk his ass up!
Oh my god, I'm dying.
Please don't pick on me.
I'm tiny.
I'm so cute and...
That's what I remember!
Oh, you put back to sleep!
I'm helping, I'm helping.
Helping to wake his ass up.
Okay, then it's the skinny one.
Go away.
He's scaring us.
Ah, no, only Amelot to use magic.
Do you believe in magic?
I don't even think you need to put him to sleep anymore.
Well, our last one spawns in.
He's E.P. He is E.P.
Oh, there we go.
Sorry, the trap.
Oh, I need to...
I'm out.
Oh, wait, hold on.
Let me chug this real quick.
Oh, he's getting him!
I remember...
Oh, I need to heal.
Hold on.
Let me heal.
Oh, I did it. See, I did the final blow.
Well, I was in the corner of the room,
super safe. No, I did the final blow.
What are you talking about?
It was all me, baby.
It was all me.
You're killing them too fast.
Oh, no, we...
We are so overleveled for this.
We're so so overleveled.
I need to go on the left or right.
Left or right?
This way?
Kind of looks like this way.
Surely.
What are you...
There's another grace site, which means more leaflings!
Hello, Mr. Grace site.
It's a pleasure to meet you.
Please, no, no, allow me.
Bring my children to me.
Wrong way, damn it.
Okay, let me level up.
That it?
Sure, I'm just going to max out on health,
because...
What does it matter at this point?
Oh, my God, I have an extra tier thing as well.
A flask.
It was a 50-50.
And we got there in the end.
Oh, it's Gimli!
And my axe.
How is there a summon thing here?
Why is there only one leafling?
Is there another point here where you guys are?
Hmm?
Is it here?
I don't see it.
Hmm?
Is it here? I don't see it.
Can you guide me? Do you know where to go?
Why are we stealthing?
And then we can get more leaflings
and then at the next point, wherever it is?
Oh.
Oh, that's way too early.
No!
Close enough, close enough.
Okay.
You just point us in the right direction.
I'm...
Like...
Yeah.
I'm going to, like, super health out.
Even though the drip was real.
You jump over here?
Gentle.
And then we get...
Whoa!
Stop it!
With my...
Hmm?
Okay.
Huh?
Oh!
Someone's ahead!
Hi, leafling!
Who's here?
You're a fucking snake in the fucker, though.
Leafling?
Oh!
You almost died!
See, this is why you can't be away from mommy too long.
Don't do that again.
You scared me. Don't do it again.
Is that leafling coming in?
I have backup.
See, look, I brought backup.
We're all safe now.
Hmm.
What's up here?
Okay.
See?
First of all, you need me.
I just came in clutch for you.
What?
Here?
Something incredible ahead.
What?
We go back down?
Huh?
Huh? I'm literally that cat meme right now.
Okay.
I don't know how you guys, like,
remember it as well, being like,
I don't know what step comes next.
Or do you have the wiki open right now?
Be honest.
Do you have the wiki open to get rid of my scarlet rot?
Oh, no, not scarlet rot.
A frenzied flame.
We're hugging the wall.
Do you stop him?
Yeah, fucking knock off.
Yeah, get him, get him, get him!
Gang violence!
Okay, let me cover my stamina.
Is that a summoning thing down there?
Ah!
Wifling!
No wiki, just pure knowledge and skill.
Is there an enemy wifling here?
Uh, this gray site is called
Dragon Temple rooftop
if there's an enemy who wants to come in.
Oh, Madame Missouri!
Mm, mm, mm, mm, mm, mm, mm.
Chat's wisdom just
is really spectacular.
There's no enemy wiflings, I can't believe it.
Careful of lightning, I have.
Is it too dangerous?
Oh, ding!
What am I even having?
I'm supposed to say your name, what even was that?
And you come.
There, you get a new nickname.
Aina Onoho, there you go, all yours.
That's the main character from Overload?
Oh my god, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
Okay, take us.
Show me the way.
Show me the way to victory, to victory, to victory.
Show me the way to victory, all along the way.
I think there's a fight ahead.
Oh.
Mm.
Oh, is this this run sprint section?
I think we have to just keep running.
Like, literally ignore the birds and keep running.
Yeah.
Yep, I'm getting a memory.
And then this dragon's a fake dragon.
He doesn't actually want to fight us.
He flies away at a later date.
Oh.
He's a fake dragon.
Let me guess.
They can't get hurt by environmental things like that.
But I can.
Fake dragon, he's gone.
Falcons aren't fake anyway.
They're coming for blood.
I can't.
There we go.
Oh, nice heal, nice heal.
Oh, they seem to be stuck over there.
Mm.
I've never seen a single try finger,
but I don't really read the messages
because the last time I read them,
it goes Fortnite and I'm like,
I just got Fortnated.
Fortnite's panel pen.
Wait a minute.
Did I ever get an update about the music video
for Amy's thing yet?
Hold on, hold on.
Let me just fucking message management.
Amy's Fortnite battle pass
should have came out ages ago.
Uh, Amy's Fortnite
battle pass
music video
question mark.
Sorry.
It's hard being a mother and a mummy
at the same time, you know?
I don't even know
how I did that.
Am I just go for it and then I'll pick you up
on the other side?
Ah, I'm awfully mailing.
Right, you killed the dragon.
Oh, you made the dragons back!
The dragon doesn't remember
being taken away.
Reflings take this dragon's balls.
Mm.
Ow, my back.
My neck and my crack.
No, it didn't become an, where's Taurin?
Taurin?
Is Taurin too scared to be spawned here?
Because honestly, same.
My owner was like,
get it up, come on, I want to go.
Oh, I can keep my souls.
I was rather kind of the game.
How are you aggro to me already?
Whoa.
Leave me alone!
No!
No, leave me alone, I refuse.
Oh, it's our boss!
Oh my god, I need my refunds now.
Okay, hold on, hold on.
Let me stop fucking up, hold on.
Let me get my thing back.
Oh fuck it, no, I'm going in, sorry.
Sorry, there's too many, I'm scared.
Master Scott, oh, this isn't a boss!
Oh!
Everything's getting worse!
Everything's getting worse without you, Refling.
Why aren't you, oh, go up the lift!
Please just go up the lift.
Please, oh, safety, okay.
Okay, this is better.
There's a new area in the enemies.
Oh, thank you.
Oh my god.
Don't, don't do that to me again.
Do you understand?
Say yes, Mummy.
Yes, Mummy, I love you again.
Thank you, good to see you.
And good boy, you deserve all the treaties to me.
And all the take away you deserve.
For no particular reason.
Major reason?
I think there's a few Reflings that haven't had a chance to play with me yet.
I'm not sure.
Come, come on, what are you doing?
Yeah, you've not been a good Refling.
Unable to summit, god.
I don't know what.
Carpet bomb, you're a naughty Refling.
You're a naked Refling, that's what you are.
You're original, aren't you?
I'm gonna try
and get chicken pie
since I'm going to get my nails done.
No dragon? Wait, am I supposed to do a dragon?
I recommend doing
dragon first so we can show you the way down.
Just go back to the dragon.
Are we going back?
Oh, I did not expect that, I'm gonna be honest.
You broke my game!
Stop breaking my game!
Stop it, right, let's try again.
You crashed again.
I've never crashed.
I don't know why it's having such a team.
It's having like a
such a rough team.
It's having such a hard time processing.
I don't know what's going on.
Jarhead jumpscares the game engine.
We broke the bed.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I know there's less
freaking loss or progress.
We're just having a stroke, right. Hydration check, hydration check.
So I need to go back, kill the dragon,
and then we finish the game?
So what?
A colleague is in here at the
at the Great Bridge, and then we go back
down.
I am just
spin to window, I'll mark off
everyone's name.
Oh.
Spin to win.
You just had a thought.
My ex, you carried me a little bit.
No, I'm even not had a chance to do.
Is it you that keeps breaking my game?
I
I said you that keeps breaking my game
unironically.
I'm scared to call you in.
Maybe it's I'm right
if my game breaks after this.
You need to start
like, I don't know.
It should be fine.
Yeah, bye.
If my game crashes,
I know it's you.
And I can't believe it.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Other reason not here yet.
You're beautiful.
Apologies.
Ready?
The wagon plane.
Are you Neo?
Literally, damn right you fucking Neo.
I swear God, if you fucking break this
PC again.
I'm going to get you bad.
I'm going to get you bad if this
freaking PC, this game shuts down one
time.
Whoa.
Who's doing that?
That's no me.
Is that light and friendly or dangerous?
More balls for my collection.
Get her frustrated
so she greets.
What's wrong with that?
This is
fucker.
Oh wait, this isn't going to work.
I have to go in on my own?
No.
You guys are going to have to de-spawn.
I have to go in on my own?
Are you from here?
Do I have to do the dragon fight
on my own?
Don't say lock in.
What are you posing for?
Get out of here.
Okay, well, I'll mark off
no one's name count at that time.
You took me like two centimeters across the map.
Ugh.
I should be able to summon
for the fight.
Oh yeah, I've vanquished
so hard.
I've vanquished so hard.
You're beyond the bounty.
The boundaries of the multiplayer.
Oh, you're like right down there.
How?
What?
This game is such a-
How do you snipe so well?
You snipe too well.
You need to give the other refunds
I haven't had the chance to.
I swear if that's you down there.
I don't know how you are sniping this well.
I'm literally walking into it.
I swear.
Okay, dragon bench.
You can come in.
I did that thing just as a proof
of concept.
They approved it, I guess.
If there's anyone else that wants to be here.
Sir Rush?
You lagged out or something happened?
Is your name smart enough for it to be?
I won't do an evil refland
because if we're about to do a boss fight
you get despawned anyway.
They're-
They're playing the level along with you
and single for a keyboard.
Do I need to use the needle
before I kill him?
Do I?
After?
Okay, after. Got it.
Where'd I go now?
Show me, show me, show me, before we get invaded
on this little rock.
I'm falling.
I'm trying to get like you, my boy.
Surely I won't fall off the map.
Surely.
Is this the thing where it like
sucks you into it and I have to interact
with something to get sucked in?
Lie down?
Sure. Why not?
I don't see why not. Me and the boys
just lying down.
What bizarre transitions
into like fights
and stuff?
Is it literally like it sucked into the vortex?
I don't remember much of this at all.
We're going back in time.
I'm going to the past when like
it wasn't a vortex.
That's rather blinding.
As if it's not first thing in the morning.
Futurelings, are you here too?
Oh no, pastlings, are you here?
There's a big old arena.
Oh, I'm going into the past to fight the first Elden Lord.
That's cool concept.
I like that prehistorical reason.
Unscramble your
Farum Azula.
He's got two heads?
Do you have two? Oh, you do.
Okay.
Leechlings?
Honestly, we run around.
Dustling.
That's not the same song
that we were singing at all.
Time for precious item.
You go first.
Let me push you forward.
Is there a cutscene?
Or do we just start swinging?
We just start swinging. There's no cutscene.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I'm hiding behind this pillar.
You guys keep going.
Go on without me.
Did one?
Did I go up to him and hit him?
I'm a bit scared.
Am I?
Okay.
I'm helping, I'm helping.
Okay, I'm out of hydration.
Whoa, whoa.
Um...
Can I just support from the sidelines?
I don't do this.
I mean, you're killing him.
His freaking breath is...
really dangerous, though.
Is there implied a third head
that got cut off or something?
What does that mean?
I'm too scared to be near him.
Yeah, that's why.
I didn't even...
I didn't even have time to react to the lightning move.
Whoa.
What did you do?
I heard him.
I see him.
Okay.
They really like the enemies
that come flying in.
They're like, yeah, we love them.
We'll go first tail.
Bael took three of his heads.
Oh, he used to be bigger.
I was going to say that looks
like where a third one should be.
A little spank here and there.
Okay, let me back up.
I need to play this super safe.
Hey, y'all.
There, nice.
Oh, you poisoned him.
You are...
Don't worry, I got his tail.
You guys just keep doing the good thing
or whatever it is you're doing.
Just keep it up.
Ow.
I can't refling down.
No.
Refling.
No, what happened?
Well,
this is dangerous.
This is very dangerous.
Because I'm...
Oh, no.
This is dangerous.
What happened?
I can't even get there.
I can't even get up to him.
Oh.
Okay, maybe the old lock
like thing does have its benefits.
Where is he?
I have no idea where he is.
I'm just happy to be here.
He's got laser beams.
Oh.
That thing almost one shot me.
Oh, my God.
Living up to the name Dragonbish,
but God, damn.
What?
That laser beam almost got me.
Jeez.
What do we do now?
First try. Yeah, it was totally me.
I did so much damage.
Get to the grace and use the needle at the grace.
Okay.
Hello, Mr. Grace site. How's your weight against?
There's not too many.
Rest at the grace site.
Oh, I can't use it.
Then I'll do it here.
Oh, using the inventory.
Sorry. Sorry. Sorry.
I knew that.
Are you?
Micaela's needle?
Subdues are once accepted frenzied flame.
This one?
It's this one, isn't it?
Yeah.
Yeah, this one.
Yeah, okay.
Okay, I'll just make it shit.
Thank you, darling.
Use
to tame this flame of frenzied.
Did I just
stop myself in the eye with that?
Okay, where did I go now?
And you could burn the entire world.
No, I want my maiden alive.
I know you're cured. Travel back
to say the great bridge.
The great bridge.
Do I use a pill?
Funnily enough, killing the dragon was not needed
to do the flame.
Did you guys just want to do the dragon fate?
Be honest.
Did you just want to do the dragon fate?
Okay, spin your names marked out,
because I think something happened.
Just in action.
Is it you?
Dizzy, you two, you never got him.
Spinning to ween.
Dizzy.
Follow the bridge and kill the horse knight.
Say no more.
If you break my PC,
ass with.
To everything you hold deep.
Insert the purple clip where she's like
I want to shoot up him.
You get that pure strength.
I'm gonna look at you. I'm so royal.
Okay, there we go.
You can use it, then die and not have to fight.
Pretty sure you have to be in the arena
for at least a third to one.
I thought it was required.
Okay, a fight.
Is this the bowling ball place?
No, this is just a knight.
Crystal ball, a person, a thingy-mobobber.
Come, we will attack at once.
We will take our golden runes and be gone.
We will deal devastating blows.
Oh my gosh.
Can I just have yous all the time?
So you don't despawn?
This then, I forgot.
I don't know what fight this is.
Is this someone where he turns red?
In phase two?
I truly have forgotten what an air this one is.
He looks like the guy that you feed the death routes to...
Oh, I missed.
I missed again, sorry.
How are you keeping up with his speed?
I can't even make it to him.
It's him, oh.
Oh wait, that's the death route guy we feed?
I feel really bad.
Is he still in Caleb after we finish this?
Is it kind of just one of those game things?
We got to put him down.
Oh dear.
Oh yeah, he's the red guy all right.
You guys know how to kill that, right?
He wants death route to get the part of death and death he lost to Rani.
Yeah, like Rani did it to him.
If you give him all of the death route,
he gets sad that he needs to fight you.
Oh really, there's hidden guys?
I wonder what he says.
I'm feeling a little modeling.
Send him to the farm upstate at once.
Oh.
May I please think?
Death and death?
May I please think for a moment?
Okay, I missed.
And I'm out of stamina, hold on. Let me recover my stamina.
How am I doing this?
How does he...
He's so agile, like so quick agile that you can't even...
You can't even...
How does this get taken off of me?
Did you guys see how skinny my health bar was?
They went on to reset me.
I'm too scared to go into him after that move.
He's so agile and small.
I can't...
Right, he's like hiding from me.
There, I did 400 damage.
I did another cheeky 400.
No, no, no, no!
No!
Can someone do the final blow just while he's attacking me?
Just while he's attacking me, you know?
Thank you!
Yeah, I was stuck, you know?
I was stuck in a little hard position.
I got an achievement.
Mikhail with black play.
Oh, that's in time.
What is that?
That's a fanny.
Sorry.
Absolute child.
And now the fire on the air dream can actually burn it.
It's a song.
Sorry, my graphics are on low, so I think that's supposed to be a bit higher.
Oh, death and death, okay.
So now the whole world can die now.
Oh, I forgot about those old wee waves at the table.
Does everyone know?
They're both the ones.
Oh, I forgot we did a wee bit of Orson.
You added the death set, so now the concept of death exists in between them.
Wee bit of fire, just a wee bit.
I just a wee bit, no.
Anyway, no, you didn't need to call it a wee fire, man.
It's fine.
Like, finally we can die.
Yeah, I thought there was some Elden Ring or like that, that were like, oh, we just want to die, but they can't.
They basically said I'm a muffin.
Please, I just want to die!
Have you had a muffin today?
Welcome to Ashen Capital.
Can you still stream Snape if I'm in this stage of the game?
Oh, well, that answered that question.
That answered that other question.
Oh, no, sorry, sorry, I sat down.
Hi!
Okay, let's check who hasn't had a show.
Gideon's Secret Love.
That's very specific.
I think you can't hear Gideon in his voice.
He's tapping that.
Gideon's Secret Love.
Who's not had a chance to do a good job?
Major Eastling, you did get a chance earlier.
Kyle, you got a chance earlier.
Sarah Rush, you got a chance earlier.
Norm, you disconnected.
Yeah, you did.
Or my game crashed, I think.
Gideon's Secret Love.
Are you going to be bouquet then going on?
Did they rename themselves?
Wait, am I being dumb?
Takaishi.
Sex, man.
Stop Takaishi.
Okay, where, go, go, go, take me, take me, take me, take me.
Take me to your leader.
I am Sex!
I should double that in scores.
I am Sex.
ori wa seksu?
uh a reply to umi's uh leaks with her newest update
with it and she was like strongy i've never seen this in my life and i'm like you're welcome
it is a piece of history that i will have for you
urusei ori wa snotu seksusura da
sorry i'm really getting into it tihi i'm really good at shit post them okay it's it's one of my
it's one of my skills it's one of my hobbies whoa careful okay let's see
oh is this gideon the one who rambles yeah it is are you ready
oh my god gideon's secret love you sick fuck reflin you sick fuck i get it now
i get it now you you named yourself gideon's secret lover you sick
is it coming in
he wants to struggle forever that doesn't make any sense does it what's he casting
oh my gosh
are you mourning as well in the fight oh my god you're kissing him
whatever move that is very oh sorry wait wait will we let them kiss let them kiss let them
kiss let them be the finish and move the secret lover wait did he heal
did he heal
kiss kiss kiss make out
no way that was a really good role playing i'll give you that what have i done
what have i done my lover
i did what i had to do she says oh she officers
not the double suicide oh reflin now you didn't have you don't feel well you didn't have to do that
but you could have just figured out absolute cinema interview her for be sucky yeah
oh i finally got resistance they finally gave me a few resistance ones okay next is up the tree
branch i can't get you up here
up here
because i can't summon you in here
because the game hates me specifically i've had it up to here i don't know it's all the old ladies
hmm
wait there's a fight in here is there not yeah hold on i think there's a fight in here i don't
trust it i don't trust that i seem to think there's a fight in here or am i miss remembering
so as i'm calling him back up don't care t he calling him back up no fight in there it's just a
grace point i'm gonna check that there's any more beeflands that haven't had a chance today
before i start doing right then who would be first if it's you three
i think you would be first majorly first unless you're new resolute one
okay okay let me touch this
uh or if that's the boss okay the boss fights right there so i don't need to urge tree heal
what are you you talisman
i don't know what her tree heal is but i'll take it
fastly heals hp for self and nearby allies oh it's a spell oh i like it i like it i
like it i like it okay we don't need an evil reefland because we do boss fight
hi mr oni hi reefland okay i've assembled my team avengers assemble
oh cutscene how could i forget hydration check hydration check really quickly
that's an incantation
party healer and buffer that'll be me when i do it with sin
i'll just be cheering our belt let me heal you
a long while more god oh his wee body what hold on need to do
you do a wee fart
oh no don't i guess i went back inside
long and hard did so i'll fight
rooflings assemble pure clings crying unit healings leafling prealing in clings so cute
how did you get so cute huh reefland be assured the elden ring how did i get so
okay where you're close at hand
i'm gonna beat show the street
we were born over cute moment
alas i am returned
to be granted audience once more
he is he's the calm down on the steroids his heart is gonna pop okay
upon my name as godfrey
the first elden lord okay
not the dragon uh i is this the one where he runs up to you and grabs you i think he is
it's honestly a lot more menacing when they just walk up to you
i don't remember a single thing about his attack
oh
i'm not good i'll help from afar
me get my stamina back
no i miss i hit that
whoa whoa whoa whoa i hate when i'm in an attack and i know they're about to attack but my dumb ass
is already locked in because i'm so greedy
oh what
ah he is like a
i think i just got him to hurt the reasons by accident due to my stupidity i'm sorry if that's true
oh reefland's going ham that's right spank him spank him john
is he in another
oh jeez lois he does not stop swinging that mallet that's not mallet
oh the feature
oh i made him face too i'm sorry
and then like the line takes over
let his first sona come out oh my god he's a furry
he like sacrificed it
oh he kills his furry saint but now he's just a regular man in stem
that's a shame it was grafted to his back
i've given me courtesy enough
the line with his limiter how strange
keeps his warrior side under control i guess because warriors are a bit more like
bloodlust yeah
now i fight just horror loo
warrior
warriors uh this is the one way oh struggle snuggle no thank you go away
only reefland's can do that to me
oh my gosh i
i'm gonna be alright right
um please get off me kindly
oh my gosh oh no i need to
i'm not the one all i'm saying oh
oh nice nice nice we've got a critical
oh didn't get away fast enough when he was chosen by marica he was a killing machine
oh whoa whoa whoa need to pay attention sorry we'll read lore after oh my god
i can't hi tree
okay i missed reefland's getting jumped i can't hit him he's too far away reefland i'm so sorry
ow i deserved that for my terrible oh not this again no no no no no no no no no
oh my god i think if he caught me i would have died i'm not even kidding
i honestly think he would have got me
i don't know
i stop it leave them alone they mean their best they mean no
warm
yeah see he says we deserve it he's nice thank you five for the tip
he's like so polite about it he's like oh you know what actually i do think we deserve it i'll
read it thank you reefland thank you thank you you helped a lot mommy me who did nothing
food first try
there's a thing in the elton lord where people are often granted servants in the form of an animal
i get my little baby anonymous i want to power bomb mommy like that but onto the bed honestly
i got enough
okay any butthole first off tree friend ahead
you can summon on the staircase i most certainly can tickling
is there any reefland that hasn't had the opportunity to play with me today
i don't know how you do that is this an enemy ahead friend ahead therefore be weary of boss
oh it's another fight right away
well shit
yeah it's the final boss this is the end
oh is there oh okay any more right who's not had a chance to play
big reefland you're an enemy you've not actually played on my side though
you've not played by my side you've been a naughty boy
um
rune did you get a chance to play you did
you wait what are you dressed up like me
am i going schizophrenic or can you have yourself on your team
i am you
monk oh
oh i'm not sure you what how did you even
uh let us go together me i guess come let us fight together
he's literally you how did you do that oh my god we're like genuinely identical
that's a what a freight and and thought oh no he does the head pass like me and everything
there's a talisman that can make him look like yeah okay first time let's see what happened
two mummies
do you think he could handle two mummies he's the better scrawny honestly
yeah i'm not gonna argue what's this what's this my brain has forgotten
for hayton kept for hayton i just made that work out by the way i don't think that's a natural word in
watch
whoa what oh
he's crunching popcorn popcorn back there really popcorn
behold gold behold dog
it cuddling
oh so this is a man
meal and stream back
Google credit for hayton has forgotten and that's wet my arse remembered
clean probably
that's marica now you're a man a manly man oh he's a femboy it's a woman that turns into a man
what is elden ring trying to say the dlc is about a fucking femboy a little second what's going on
what's the agendination okay what's the agenda
uh i do not recall a single thing from this so let's see what happens
okay that looks like a holy spell forever every single
they said i don't like that reefling in particular rid no no thunder
oh
it's my reefling down no one reeflings down our feet reefling down reefling down
oh my gosh how do you have enough time to do magic
how ah i put me down put me down get off of me i go spanked halfway across the battlefield
oh my god not me and not me and me doing it perfectly in sync with the jump freaking thing
no wait you even have the same sword art how
how did you do that i didn't know how you did that
uh
you can lock in strontis
shit we're sharing the same brain cell i'm trying i want you to with mimic tears
oh my tummy made a noise oh no wait i think i remember
uh
oh
me and me are supposed to kill this
um
i think it's compensating for sun
um i do not recall what happened
or what the attacks are okay we've got flames understood haven't i say oh and i got double
touched by them na hydrate well strony 2.0 is already doing better than me
oh my gosh okay one
okay strony got hit
okay whoa i missed the jump
how are you fey and well under it how is it not getting you i have no idea
it's shaining it's shaining what does it mean i don't know
whoa well i mean i went for strony so i'm just glad
this fate is far too beautiful for me to die it's gone for you
okay now it's how it's so i can't even get close to it to even hurt it
uh okay flames flames got it coming in coming in okay completely missed don't worry completely
missed the drive-by can't win them all can't win them all on the edge on the edge uh completely
get wallops oh you can't you cast some bubble thank you i mean thank thank me yeah thank me
someone in the group became a lord yay i got the notification okay i'm getting
sorry i'm getting too distracted hold on let's actually attack this guy and give him some damage okay
let me
okay he is going for you he does not care about me at all
oh i just got walloped
no don't make me do it on my own no
whoa what the fuck
no don't spew no pure kling knock it off pure kling no out out pure kling knock off stop it
all right i'm resetting i want i don't want to win on my own i want to win with my reflans
i'm resetting i have to be with my reflans when i win or else it's not a win
you did mommy died okay oh no it's at the top of the stairs into it okay there's big
reflans in here
all this destruction and death you how are you already there you just died
thronger you've not would it be throngler and ruin would be next possibly i think it would be
ruin and thronger
you're the next joe hey you got it to less than half alone yeah completely on my own
this gets brand new
beep beep beep
we are see that's what i'm going to do i'm going to do that again ready steady we're totally
going to do this oh we have to do the mini fight again don't we oh no oh no this can't be
okay okay we're skipping the thingy oh that's right we have to do the fight against okay
okay okay okay
okay okay let me get let me be clear i'm at i'm gonna get my energies back
oh i deserved that i deserved it i deserved that i'll admit it i'll be first in a minute
no come on that should it oh please don't die now
i couldn't roll off of it t-heat my fellow americans i couldn't roll off of it
sorry sorry i couldn't roll off of it no don't puke it's fine i promise it's fine
i have plenty of spawning okay plenty i promise i promise i promise it's alright it's alright
then you puke no stop put it back in your throat swallow it swallow it swallow it
this should do something bad i died i died i died i i died okay our new jewel is not alessandro
and just a fellow don't don't pick you're gonna upset yourself
okay yeah i'm scared too i don't think this morning i think we're scared right good luck
look surely i won't mess it up completely whoa
i'm ran from my head girl okay let's go let's go let's go easy peasy no blood
okay there we go
uh-huh i'm back off i'ma get my energies back okay i'm gonna still get hit anyways oh i i
okay it's got there's a if the ground is glowing he's not done okay if it's glowing he's not done
sorry that probably was rather obvious oh i did it again
no the ground is going okay and
ice is terrible oh it's just terrible oh i'm getting freaking couple of moods
right hold on let me hydrate
oh good okay we got it okay nice critical hit critical hit
hit is that friendly or is that enemy what is that
leave him alone he's mine not yours okay right this time this time we got it we got it in the
bag in the bag in the bag in the bag in the bag in the bag oh okay i'm skipping the cut scene so
have a stream sniping the boss is off okay i can't you see nothing when it does that you know that
i can't you see i hang when it locks on like that
that's any kind of it you bought whoa
i almost fair i don't okay
it's fine
i'm freaking heal uh energy
okay okay okay okay we're all still up we're all still up
i don't i don't am i in the i know what please don't do that camera please don't
oh what does it mean ow ow ow what does it mean
i don't i don't know how i've aided that i feel like i was literally you know in tennis where
they bring up the camera and they're like out yeah that felt like that when they had to bring up the
camera because no one could tell if i had it or not
uh
i want to try and keep my freaking dam in a high but it's not working
i says i get over to the boss yeah i mean
okay i'm just bad i'll admit it i admit it take this i'm helping
okay i missed again and i missed and i missed again and then i'm out of stamina okay i got
that time yeah take that oh you got him you poised him
oh you got critical hit
do it do it do it yay we did it we're Elden Lords together can i be your Elden Lady
i'm your Elden Lady i'm your Elden Lady
i'm your Elden Lady we did it we did it oh that's the time
hello chat okay now we're just doing a touch fractured marica
aye go on then i'll put it together i'll mend it together here you go hen i'll put you put you back
to where you belong i'm not doing Rani i'm doing me
i'm not doing Rani
i do Rani every time i'm the Elden Lord
mmm
i'm not going to the stars this time i'm the boss
so i say we're thank you to get to my mouth
now comes the age of the reeflings all shall be milked and no eternal pleasure
well eternal and internal
the best age known and the only reason our age came to an end is because we went to the farm
after the fallen leaves tell a story yeah
of how a tarnished became Elden Lord yes in our home across the fog the lands between
us
i see we'll look back upon us and recall
i look at me i'm a level one an edge of fracture
yes yes yes
when the intern becomes the CEO literally
ah i've never been Elden Lord before an age of milking
world great wait george r r martin was a part of this
explains why the plot was meant oh i'm good um we did it
age of mummy is in i've never been Elden Lord i always end up doing Rani because i'm
like ah my doll wave she's so cute and you didn't know no i thought it was all by from
okay good night
well done thank you for everyone's help i mean this is quite a full list uh i could you know i
take a little cheeky full okay post it later actually i should you know what i'll post a
collage of all of us playing together because i have like all the papers from the different
games of play like um like team scouts honor from overwatch and then like team writer hardly
even know her baby's question did sir green green red like i have so many stream snake papers
the problem is i write on some of them that have notes for failure on it so i can't be
i can't be not censoring everything so someone's name i get censored out that's the only problem
oh like the reefland roll credits exactly basically george r martin created the universe and
meya zaki destroyed it and made it mess up oh well yeah mummy what are the first letters of all
the main characters in the game think about it rodan rodwin rodrick liliip liliip george rr
big george
wait all the characters start with george g rrm oh wait this is just a big old thing for him
no wait a minute wait a minute who are you
and do it fun fact the gods that birthed all the others godfrey ragnon
rad gone ranela america they do be getting around the gods do fancy a good shag you know what i'm
saying like they're proper going for it i'm like oh what's going on here right who's strumming is emmer's
up today is my adorable little sister up today or not i'm going to bend her over my name give her a
little spanking oh she's doing piano oh my god she's doing piano in 30 minutes oh that's so cute i
i can't say that maybe she'll talk about it i don't know what did you see was in her
application video for no particular reason okay i'll make sure i'm redirecting into my
little sister marshmallow until emmer's time you have yourself a deal i am good for the rambling
even though my voice is absolutely short
i joined at the credits congrats yeah i did it all myself this was definitely a solo run and
i wasn't carried there absolutely everything um what's the next big game you're playing
oh i don't know but this is my schedule boom boom meiko i'll go next it i'm playing i've never
played subnautica before so don't be expecting me to win at it i don't even know how you win at it
all i know is that is there's water and animals uh animals or fish animals or fish
busty crustaceans down in the water um obviously try hard run not summon no a bit magic nothing
in sight honestly honestly i believe ranny's ending is actually canon really i do like ranny
i i miss my wife tales i miss my blue doll hardcore gamer she doesn't even do it for male
attention exactly i did it all myself um your ping would be atrocious um i think
oh i think i might have to host it because you'll have to add my stream snipe account to do it
i do want to prefer prefer preference preface that stream by saying i don't know if i'll be
able to get everyone in that wants to get in because there's only two slots available each time
i miss my strong chat
oh bye thank you for hanging rest well sleep well
strongy be aware subnautica is actually a horror game do you
then you put my heart rate monitor on for it left for dead is eight players
oh wait you can do eight players and i thought it was four hold on let me
congrats on base game elden ring love the short stream to do yes three hours short stream
by the way make sure you rest the voice yes i will love you strong i love you to we've been
subnautica can be a hurricane four zombies and four people you guys can chase after us
oh i'm going to be screaming if you're coming at me i'm moving funny
the strongy voice pack that plays in my head when you're not streaming streaming hi we've been
let him get up let him get up i love my reefland i love my reefland i don't know how to say that
one real and true jobby jobby has two bees and i just so you know wink wink nudge nudge yeah
fuck you bitch bend over i'm gonna fart on your eyelash oh no have i said that have i said that
so much i do say tihi okay this is like a little bingo card of me i love this and unfortunately
order and today we're gonna pack this customer's order she doesn't even do it that badly i hope she's
in on the joke and we're and she doesn't feel like we're laughing at her i hope she's with us on the
joke uh the campaign and left for dead is four players failure rare for player consider playing
versus mode on left for dead but uh maybe play a match on normal first to get used to the game
and controls and then go against each other i feel like i'm gonna get walloped she's gonna get
annoyed that i'm on our team she's gonna be like no you go with the zombie bullshit bag you're shitting
at this giveaway okay so mommy said on versus mode but i think you might want to do it because you
don't know what it means basically it's a campaign based on the host choices with the team of four
humans and four zombies do the mission alternating between human and zombie and each team tries to
win but making it to the safe house by the end if you choose normal mode you can only get in one
refland and one here um but if you do that you can get way more okay um
hey mommy confession time oh we got our sin stream uh i was thinking about doing a confess your
sin stream but i keep i keep pushing it back like i've pushed it back to next month um every time
you say order a cringe because i'm so used to hearing the goofy Rebecca version versus it's so fun
in zombies you have to start jazz and kill off the humans one by one you can always just play
against you no i'm not gonna hurt she be in a game hey mommy confession time i have been sending
miles and talking and chat a lot but i have one confession to admit to you i can't eat chicken
anymore without getting hard all the talk about chicken and making us full and then teasing us
and our word and has made me imagine it constant have i given you f***ing pavlovye like pav is it
pavlovian have i given you pavlovye in response to chicken i eat chicken because of my tism i can
actually feel an experience that they did you know it's hella awkward with family when i eat
chicken not gonna lie just imagining you feeding us chicken thighs and breasts till we're almost full
but you say no refland you need to eat healthy so let me feed you till you're full then eventually
we are full and we see that look in your eyes of the and it's peak and you want to do it so
so we lay down in your straddles until we both ink in a glorious ending and after we're done
you lay down on us and we cuddle till we sleep yeah i'm down bad
oh uh what do i do what one what option
when we get feeding chicken ASMR fix him fix him now i think i've broken him that refland is cooked
yeah like the fried chicken and the fry right now just press no
keep reading almost done probably no you can choose yes later okay no i don't want to join
when the blood look new items can be purchased from the twin medium plus
oh god i forgot like everything
i killed everyone oh wait there's that nice lady that she doesn't she doesn't leave master
she does leave master huig oh no does he even talk anymore
can he talk about himself anymore
she should be in this starting room or did i miss her
oh she is take a look around the round table holders
raised to the ground don't worry i don't blame you i'll continue spirit tuning
just the same as before which is why i need your help persuading master huig to leave
his roots are so knotted in this place
but he doesn't realize the round table behind him
i remember that what's happening so it wasn't just me this happened to
think he'd forget who you were as well yeah he'd burn himself out old huig
i think he once said you'll be forever his lord
but it's not the only way it's better that we don't it's only proper that we respect his choice
to stay isn't his choice if he's on his right mind i'll remain with he made me i'd like to return
the kind oh yes look at all the spirit talismans i've picked up
yes because i've done regular schmagular stuff before oh the store's open hello mr door
what was behind you an item hello oh
well whatever was behind the door he did he's dead as a doornail
yeah and your armor shit get condom i assume this is like a door door yeah
he got aft by fear sheevee's cat what promiscuous little thing was it getting up to hold on a minute
if you didn't know a little sheepster's cat is named after um
yeah classic from soft no npc life alive
sheevee has an adorable little rowdy bunch of cats and one of them is called fear which is
oh is that a fight one
it is is there anything special you can tell how much i didn't do the base game for how much like
there's nothing oh this is our kitchen did that open next door i did okay i'm going to try and
not break the front at your because i'm not sure if i can get it remade now that the whole place
is on fire where am i trying to go up the stairs you should try for fear's ending next
time i think it's the best wait fear has an ending route i didn't know that i should have done that
for sheevee well i guess i'm just going to play the game again damn that's what it looks like when
you're oh
receive equipment from champions oh if i want to buy their
this is a lot
there's like but aside from frenzy and ranny they all look the same but slightly different voice
oh really that's the only difference i was going to say because ranny's the moon i know frenzy flame
bob ag meggy what's her name my maiden she go sorry um i can't even remember the names for the
life of me she um why did all the tarnish die i'm so did the tarnish die i don't understand why
all the tarnish would die as soon as this place went on fire why don't you know get out
offer a ball bearing would you like them all
there's a dunk eater wait really doesn't he not do the knotty knotty
and he makes people never die
because the box upon life itself
all the tarnish were already dead you brought death to the world oh dumb ass i remember that part
you know long i've been long with him can i smack him can i kill him right now
fear revolves around restoring death and death
uh can i smack him try it oh i can't oh you can't fight in the round table
i don't know if you can hear that let's me spam in my trigger you can't fight in the round table
you could try find his body under the capital for parishion oh jeez well this place is open place
so are we in the tree is that the question are we secretly the tarnished we're always
in the tree i can't believe it right if i go speak to can i even speak to um
macadamia not what's her name
did she even talk to me anymore no i can't even talk to her
oh my god i never defeated the horse at the star i hear it
surely it's time to look it's time oh why did i drink that i don't know it's time to prove i'm
a real elden lord are you ready for this
i'm proof see i'll i'll okay take that then
see i'm a real elden lord look at that enemy fell exactly
hey she hates you because you use the frenzy
to fling hi mama how's elden ring with the refling story hope you're all having fun
sorry if i asked this out of the blue but can you tell me that everything's all right
oh is it a shade day i'm sorry narrow everything's gonna be all right i promise
thank you for the tip everything works out in the end i always say this you
you have survived every other shite day that you've ever gone through you know when you're like
oh this is the worst day of my life this is the worst day of my life this is the worst day of my
life surprise surprise you survived every single worst day of your life so what's another what's
another shite day on and and the grand scheme of things what's another shite day think of all
the shite days you've had and then think of truly the heaviest details that you can genuinely
remember on those shite days you're forgetting fast you're you're chilling you're doing your thing
you know right we're gonna chill by the fire and i'll read some marshmallows you know
yeah we're just gonna oh i'm standing up again let me sit by the fire we'll get nice and cozy
we'll warm ourselves
let me read some marshmallows
uh watch a long pitch okay i mean you're a reflund really enjoyed watching
uh vivi fucking fluoride in the toothpaste anime with you so i wanted to request pluto which is
neako ura sawa's modern and reinterpretation of the first-ever anime ashriboi that's focused on
robot rights for the other in anti-war it takes place in the united states of syracia
lied about weapons of mass destruction in persia to justify invasion subtexts for cowards okay
is that your pitch okay i like your pitch it follows seven ai's participations in
wars and the aftermath okay i'll consider it i do like a cheeky robot i do like a cheeky robot
um thing hi stroney does that does you mean arctic mean you don't love us the same if we're
not fat no beanpole it means i can fatten you up i learned that terminology from you guys
apparently if you're skinny you get called a beanpole
um so no it means i have an even better opportunity to fatten you up either way i win
the house always wins i am the house in this case okay you're the gambling man and i am the house i
always win it's it's five nights at freddy's out here i always come back i always win
do not think i am incapable of squeezing my any type of fetish out of you i assure you i can make
it happen good morning good morning to you don't read don't read
i did i did not read a tea it still kills me that i'm over here losing weight so
someone might look at my generation you're over here when i set my thumb
wait why does that kill you you have to remember you must you must my fellow
americans you must remember that if you are taking your concepts from the internet and stuff
there's a thing called rage bait and all that she be gone bomb get right thank you crazy jsc
for the tip that is very cat these are very high praise for someone who this is my fellow
americans this is brain dead and brain rot does mean okay willian afton mentioned why yes i too
critique in five nights at freddy's what's that why is finnaf so perfectly geared towards the
lore when it comes to whammin who knows they they hit the nail on the head
sorry if i'm a bit late to the topic when i did frenzied flame the lady wouldn't speak to me
for most of the game because she now sees me as an enemy even when i got rid of the yeah i thought
she was gonna talk to me again and be like i'm mad at you but at least i'm alive yeah that did
not happen stash power we got played we got played we went through all of that to get that needle
to become unfrenzied and we got played kind of wish i just knew the place now kind of wish i just
kept it all honestly um malena says she'll kill you after the frenzy yeah so i took it off i kept her
alive uh no it's her purpose in life to fix things or at least in her eyes to sacrifice herself
yeah that's a brain rot she got from her mom how many enemies do you have left to finish the
we finished we did it i got carried all the way through the game we finished can't have
fingermaiden well time to burn everything literally we should have had you do hayata's
quest she becomes your new maiden for the frenzied ending oh that's cool
it's hayata that one that scared that was supposed to get grafted no no she's the one
she's probably pissed that she didn't get to do the arson herself until the end you still remain
maidenless how dare you she breeery how many endings does elden ring have
five apparently but two mean ones hayata dies when you get a frenzy
whoa maybe you can do the frenzied fire ending as a mage next time yeah that would be cool
i'm definitely doing magic next time i'll play this i'm definitely doing magic next time
i'm gonna do i'm gonna do
heavens lost property is a good anime oh that's a really good name in general though heavens lost
property
i should really enjoy that
so if you ever do fan meet up at convention what cosplays do you want to see a big guy do
him draw blanks other than roadhog from overwatch i don't know what cosplay
i'm trying to i can't think of what cosplay do you know i've ever seen those tiktoks where
it was like folk like thirsting over like the college you guys were like the masks on and that
i'm being like oh i'm so thirsty for this i never really got that i don't understand the mask thing
i think it's like a major uh special interest for the majority but i never understood the mask
thing hold on let me type it in why are women so interested in masks in the bedroom let's see
if we have a logical reasoning internet what are some reasons for a mask special interest
i have a mask special interest mask men are so mysterious and attractive especially masked
horror villains like ghostface jason there he's it's a shame there's not more villains like them
hmm
uh
because men have ugly faces it's raffling what are you wow where did that come from
masks provide a sense of anonymity so you can exit your comfort zone easier as well oh
oh so i can be even more molest that's terrible don't say that i would um i like to wear masks
because it gives me a sense of power of control on top of my dominance i feel like michael mayers
or jason burghese masks who the fuck is burghese master also uses a tool i cover my face to hide
my true self once i feel my sub has earned the right to see the real me i take it off and allow
them to kiss me oh that was that was so wholesome that just got really wholesome at the end there
i didn't expect that what nice little comment onto a little sprinkle
ugly all faces towards butter jess all right okay okay okay you mean men on us be up that
reflin he meamed on us and he got me good okay awesome jason burghese is from friday the 13th
oh the the machete guy women bonk with their brains men bonk with their eyes
michael mayers is from halloween i could have sworn so i didn't know it was from a movie so in
call of duty there's this lobby type called michael mayers right and i didn't know why it was called
that i used to just play it and you get chased around with a knife and everyone gets like faster
and all that and it gets crazy and i was like who the fuck is this person why do i hear his name
all the time how are they how is the call of duty leaking into real life they're like no dumb ass
it's a real person um shawnton behavior shawnton mummy i need to be your concert to be milked
and ink daily to your satisfaction it's a new desire of mine to have helped you become the
elden lord love you love you i'm your elden lady and you're my elden lord and together we're going
to rule in the age of milking ha ha ha there's also a game called dead by daylight i've played it i
did a club oh is the end dead by daylight is that the mech am i is that the mask one i can't
remember i've not seen the horror films i don't really watch for it i'm sorry i'm sorry
hey mom a fellow reefland said something about this in chat and i had to put these edits together
while watching you and others spank elden ring i'm not sure if it's gonna work monkey
ask her if there's a picture of you peeling it back i'm in trouble
oh no way
it's not a pinterest don't worry it's not a pinterest
oh my god that's so fucking cute oh my god i'm adding it right now fuck you
you fuck you i'm updating the emotes right now how do you give me something so adorable
oh my god no wait wait i'm adding the emotes right now
so do you make something so adorable fuck it i don't need to order emotes anymore i'm just getting
you to do the wait hold on right earnings and then i need to go membership tab and then i need to go
to customize default perks and then go to emojis and then see that heart emoji
love me reefland number 14 get out of here you're becoming an emote you're becoming
and then you're becoming
oh my god right you're not ready for what's about to show up you are not ready for what's about to
show up okay it's saving right refresh and try 14 and 15
show me what you see on 14 and 15 if you refresh your page and do emotes
please work please work please work oh wow oh it's broke wait whoa
oh my god look it's you eat in oh no nom doesn't work wait why does nom not work
you're eating spaghetti
nom got nom literally i don't know why no i can do it mouth wipe though
nom nom nom we do eat it again on mouth like reefling 4 you got spaghetti all over you you're
so cute thank you reefland who sent that oh my god just look here i don't know
h word post you can skip if it's too inappropriate let's see how far we can get into it okay
okay mommy i want to wrap your sweaty gamer hoodie around my head will you
throw my tentacle i want to be unable to ink without your scent please make oh please make
me yours only and ruin me mommy i've even got a belly for you uh you want scent play
our mommy even wipes her mouth i don't know why the other one wait we get spaghetti yeah i'm feeding
you it's so cute why is the gnome one not working it's like the cutest one ever
did it did the upload fail
i working on my aim
nope hmm oh is it working on your end oh okay okay i'm i'm dumb i'm just very dumb
i'm small brain i see it now i see it now it's because i don't have my glasses on
um hi mommy thanks for the elden ring stream you're welcome it's always been some of the
few streams i should feel like i can fully interact yeah i'm happy i got the opportunity
to play yeah thank you for playing thank you everyone who showed up as well even if you were
lurking in the shadows i know some people get scared to stream snipe but i'm trying to bring
you out of your comfort zone there's a membership stream snipe so that's for people who are super
super scared of me don't be scared there'll be four other reeflings on the team okay don't be shy
i love spaghetti um sorry i can't play with you no no no don't worry uh lots of fun watching
stream good runs love you love you too love me mom is it okay to love an anime girl on the internet
not be interested in real life relationship is it detrimental that's that's where things that's
where i get nervous i get scared is if it is it detrimental that's where we start being we need
to analyze what's going on here what's going on here i need to make sure you're healthy your health
number one priority listen your health number one priority okay i need to make sure you're healthy
are you healthy wealthy and wise are you behaving if you're happy i'm happy but you need to make
sure you look after yourself so you will number one you definitely should get me out of my comfort
zone i always work yeah yeah i got you get pop pop pop pop pop pop we eat in the brainworm
oh this is so cute sorry i'm eating fresh marshmallow i'm missing a few other things
starting not really a question but i'm going to do it anyway i'm going to joke what i'm going to
blow up a giant picture of your fleet go out to a steamroller drum and run over my face what's a
street a steamroller drum what are you doing with this picture
am i being dumb steam roller drum and drive it over my face tia what's tia tia tia meaning
a mini stroke well that's clearly not what you meant to say uh transient
ice comic attack what like a steam engine roller is that oh okay
mommy i'm finally getting a dog tag we're refling on it oh are you
are you
you may be the first refling the first color
mommy do you want tummy pics am i allowed to me i'm allowed that is that allowed
is that allowed
i don't know if it's a maybe maybe
are we gonna have a refling color merch no i'm not asking fucking over market for a color
merch i think i'm getting in trouble i'm asking a very specific studio soon i was a laugh on that
okay this is just really ugly i was telling to shibi and she and i was like oh i'm gonna be
surprised for you soon and she was like is it the is it the flashlight i'm like no shibi
i was like well soon maybe i'm working on it okay i was like i mean you're not wrong i'm
maybe possibly
is that allowed or is it um exactly i was really funny the way she we were typing
these so there's just really funny the way it worked um nice johnny hi mithlyn you are my
perfect woman in every way i would love it i would love everything i know i love everything
about sorry i can't read here is a small list of what i love about your sense of humor your
laughs is my soul oh yeah you like when i have a laugh in fit when a tear drop goes on an enemy
girl's face yeah yeah you like that i love that your birth months yeah you like that you like
that fizzy juice i love your almost as degenerate as me i don't surpass you i feel like i surpass a
lot of refling i feel like i surpass a lot of you true andriel i feel like i surpass a lot of
you i don't know maybe maybe i like that you make everyone feel loved and welcome welcome welcome
welcome i love when you go 10 for your hat mode brah i was holding an injured in the cat arena
collab i was like i love listening to you to yap about the things you're passionate about also i
love your huge beach i love you johnny love you terry blend um we'll see you've got some training
to do if you want to beat me oh i think i'm pretty i'm pretty pretty
no i was i was gonna i can't remember what the story is but i could have sworn it was discovered
that there's a pc part like that common pc part that can scan your room basically and it wasn't
a conspiracy theory it was found out and all that jazz is busted and cat arena was talking and i was
like i wish i had the autism to like projectile vomit that knowledge but i don't know anything
about it like i don't know how to say it i was like i was like trembling in my chair like
like your webcam your micro yeah like all of that stuff basically but i was like oh yes keep talking
okay continue wi-fi can be used to scan your room as well yeah uh free winner like uh places
offer free wi-fi and it's just yank and all everything possible out of you um i love i love me a good
conspiracy theory that's them hey mommy this is the chickenling oh no are you guys gonna be called
chickenlings oh jimmy buzzo is live okay i'll redirect you we're in game are you oh i'm so sorry
we finished i'm completely finished elden ring the next time elden ring happens um i'm actually
going to be playing a collab on seamless co-op on this game um i'm about to redirect into my little
sister um she is playing piano so if you hold on tight you'll be redirected uh into my little sister
yes next is the dlc i've already done the dlc i was in part four the yesterday's stream that was
12 hours long that was the dlc we came back to base game i'm so sorry but don't worry i have loads
of stream sniping games in the future uh if you were trying to stream snipe so please don't worry
please don't worry mama um i'm gonna redirect into my little sister okay um
okay serious question time right give me one serious question how do you feel having launched
your company with such success i hope you're over the moon and that being in charge isn't wean you
down too much i'm thrilled with how things have turned out and your talents are all amazing oh
great work so far can't wait to see and the rest of the journey takes oh thank you that was so nice
um i just i don't really have words for it i'm just happy that the girls are succeeding like
obviously immy hit 50k she's already halfway to a play button and i'm like honestly like deep in
my heart i'm like all of them deserve a play button all of them like deserve like recognition
for how you finished a whole dlc in 12 hours hold on a minute hold on a minute hold on a minute
before you start going around with that i got carried through the entire game uh my fellow
mergin like i just feel like all the girls just try so hard and do their best and like that's the
thing about being able to pick the girls i i've said this before i see the um the what's the word
what's the word i see the i see snowboard and i see stop i see the full potential that they have
and that they can reach and i know they can do it um you know it's obviously just whether a question
if they take that leap of faith or not uh yeah see the potential yeah yeah yeah so what you're
going to do next i'm going to redirect into emmy bezu and then i'm going for a nap and getting my
nails did like a girl because i'm a real girl um but yeah thank you for such a nice question
um but yeah i uh my reefland's gonna be okay if i redirect into lotsus
mommy i'm not feeling well you know well you need kisses how many kisses i don't know how many how
many rate how many i'll do a kiss for every uh reefland that uh stream snip okay but you still
get the kisses too even if you didn't stream snipe or alert okay because i know you're a shy boy
are you kidding again okay and then
okay and then keep it going
um
and last but certainly not least
there you go i see you give a good risk tomorrow that's the pro at one literally man thank you
mommy no thank you reefland thank you for playing games with me and thank you for letting me play
games that would be inaccessible to me otherwise due to my pure stupidity um but i love you lots
and i'll see you tomorrow for some hand cam we're building my lego hobby set i'm so excited you get
to see my hands tomorrow gee i wonder what kind of fancy nail polish and color scheme i'm going to have
okay super cool and awesome but i'll put up my streams uh for next week okay so thank you so
so much i'll see you tomorrow okay bye bye bye i give you kiss me good reefland good boy keep
carrying pop up okay enjoy and me say hi to me for me bye